[Music]
that
a
[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]
you
oh
[Music]
back
back oo
oh
[Music]
W back back
[Applause]
[Music]
for
sh I
[Music]
oh
for e
[Music]
oh
d
[Music]
h
w
[Music]
h
the
[Music]
h for
h
[Music]
all
oh
[Music]
n
sh
[Music]
do we have any kind of
FL before
[Music]
okay perfect perfect
hello perfect hey guys thank you so much
for coming it's a pleasure to have you
all I think you're going to have a
interesting Workshop uh today we have uh
several tracks I'm going to cover uh
each and every one of them so we can get
a sense on how it will evolve throughout
the next few hours uh we have a I think
a nice mix of uh people from traditional
finance and defi so I think kind of adds
the right flavor to the conversation uh
and it's a pleasure to be here at Devcon
and explain how especially trfi is uh
adopting and incorporating the core of
the its teex stch evm technology
ethereum
technology uh so today uh the agenda is
this one so we're going to start with a
few opening remarks going to cover the
landscape set a little bit of the tone
uh real quick introduction but I think
uh the interesting part will be the the
panels so we're going to have a first uh
panel with people from uh the industry
uh both of the the tech part and the
financial industry having a deep
conversation on on how like Global
projects are leveraging this type of
Technologies and blockchain at its core
then we're going to have uh some
highlights some case studies uh and I'm
going to Showcase some companies that
are building and doing so kind of helps
to illustrate how the industry is moving
forward uh and finally we have a last uh
session uh that I think everybody here
already heard about a lot of industry
and Enterprise efforts more on the
permission side of Def fense right but
there are a lot of opportunities and I
think uh having like a global Rao as
ethereum and public permissionless
blockchains would be very powerful and
how this industry is moving uh to to to
permissionless Innovation and public
ledgers uh all these three panels we're
going to uh be covering for around like
30 minutes each uh and we have uh three
panelists and one moderator and
afterwards uh when you wrap up the third
panel you're going to have some Q&A some
highlights as well and and then we say
goodbye but thank you so much uh uh for
coming here I think we'll be quite
interesting to get your inputs as well
so please do engage uh even though we
have a Q&A session if you feel like uh
contributing raise your hand at some
point I will be happy to welcome any
kind of questions and inputs I think it
it's kind of like a broader discussion
that we're having with everyone here
today so uh starting with the opening
remarks uh maybe a little bit of
background on myself uh I was uh
formerly
the Trad fi side let's put it like that
I I was working for the the Central Bank
of Brazil for a lot of years I was the
project manager the deputy head of the
Brazilian Central Bank digital currency
initiative which is called Drex and it's
using uh evm technology uh to put
together and to put on top of the whole
banking industry and the whole Capital
markets industry on these nextg rails
this blockchain based rails uh currently
I work for Valor Capal I'm leading
Investments on blockchain emerging
Technologies more broadly uh it's
Capital firm based in the US with a lot
of coverage on Emerging Markets having
invested in companies such as coinbase
since 2014 cirle uh C we invested in
that parabus flow and almost like 30
companies that are blockchain related
out of 130 perolio companies uh maybe
half of them are fintech so I think it's
nice to bring this kind of overlap
between blockchain and and
fintech uh but just to set the tone I
think uh going to be spending a few
minutes here uh this is actually what's
happening and what has been happening
for a long time in in the financial
industry I think this movement from uh
physical with payments with actual money
uh with uh systems uh that are actual
physical systems uh like such paper
facts uh the traditional financial
industry that sometimes still ongoing
right and then we have this kind of next
chapter uh where the industry is moving
to digital and I think the current very
expected next step and is the the
movement to blockchain based rails right
so I think an important thing to
highlight here it's this is like a new
mindset not only like technology it's a
new opportunity to leverage
permissionless Innovation uh a a tool
set and a smart contract layer to really
like uh H add efficiency programmability
composability everything that you see
usually in defi so there's definitely an
opportunity to reinvent the the
financial industry here and one
interesting part also when you think
about the settlement Pro process when
you're like uh exchanging assets for
payments or payments for payments or
assets for assets so the settlement part
uh when when you think about traditional
Finance you have uh kind of like a two
two two steps like different steps that
apart so we have the the messaging part
the information and the actual
settlement like going on uh in different
dimensions but with uh uh smart
contracts you have like everything all
together right you have the the atomic
settlement you have the information and
the exchange of assets uh going in the
in the the same moment which kind of
unlocks a lot of opportunities as well
but uh just also to highlight uh how big
is this opportunity I think you can see
this from different dimensions as well
you can see uh both from the asset
Dimension so when you think about
oranization of re assets it's a massive
massive industry currently when you
think about public blockchains and and
real assets mainly stable coins which
are very big by now but if you think
about traditional Finance it's a multi
trillion dollar industry right so you're
going to see probably some Tailwinds
that are coming from both infrastructure
such as blockchain based cbdc
initiatives and also regulator WIS kind
of like pushing the market in this
direction and help incorporate
blockchain technology in the core of the
financial industry but also there's an
opportunity to optimize the financial
Market infrastructure so the back end
the wholesale settlement the instant uh
payment
settlement uh with uh new technology so
think about a little bit of like a type
of cloud migration that the banks are
kind of like a going through still but
uh we're going to have like a next lag
when banks are actually incorporating at
the core of this tech blockchain
technology so uh going a little bit
further and double clicking uh as as I
mentioned uh we just like in the very
beginning of the journey think about
stable coins uh we have something a
little bit over the hundred billion
dollar you think about R assets we much
lower we I think we have a little bit
around like 30
billion dollars tokenized but if you
look across different tet classes here
you see that there are like a much much
bigger opportunity and that regulations
coming together the banks the financial
intitutions are getting uh more used to
the technology and more open to adopt so
it's just a matter of time that this uh
multi- trillion dollar business will
actually like move uh to this new tax
stack and it's of course when think
about the global figures they are huge
but even like I just to illustrate I'm
highlighting here Brazil it's also many
trilli ions of dollars uh only in a
specific country so this will be a
massive shift for
sure uh and uh the other dimension that
we had in the other slide I think is
this opportunity for Enterprises uh to
to migrate to a blockchain based tax
stack the same with Cloud there there
will be plenty of opportunities for
service service providers for uh
technology providers to help the banks
navigate in this new ecosystem uh so get
ready for uh interesting Journey uh and
a huge opportunity for many companies
that are working and building in this
industry uh and this is actually uh I
think kind of like a recent Trend that
you all all here have been seeing
especially with the big fi right
thinking about public blockchain rails
as perfect distribution rails uh for
tokenized real assets so we have black
rock tokenizing money market funds UBS
most recently uh other big fi as well in
their Journey for a longer period uh and
but I think one point that maybe uh is
not too discussed is that central banks
are actually pushing for this technology
so these central banks for instance are
incorporating in the core of the
financial industry evm compatible
infrastructure so if you look across all
the banks building uh on top of
blockchain rails H usually 90% of them
are using evm compatible uh Technologies
and if you look across all the cbdcs
that are thinking about tokenization not
only payments uh I would say that also
uh more than 90% of the all the
initiatives are evm compatible so this
is how powerful uh ethereum evm is and
and how much it is contributing to the
industry uh and the traditional uh
financing industry in this
journey uh and uh this is a personal
belief here I think um at the end of the
day we going to have uh defi protocols
money lagos a lot of the Innovation
that's coming from the permissionless uh
part of the of the of Def fense right
public blockchains really helping uh
traditional Finance uh creating and
innovate because if you if traditional
Finance is uh implementing evm
compatible rails evm compatible
infrastructures it's very easy uh to
Leverage The Open Source Innovation uh
to Leverage The the tooling uh to
leverage uh the money Legos and defi
protocols and to incorporate in the core
of of other tax tax so there's
definitely like a lot of contribution
but def there's definitely clear
ambition from specific central banks to
interoperate uh uh these rails of public
blockchains and interior more broadly so
I think this is a discussion that we're
going to have here and go deeper on this
and I think a little bit of uh what this
uh uh of this session is all about and
finally uh just to wrap up uh this brief
overview this is a little bit The
Evolution so people usually don't know
uh too much about uh how cement systems
evolve but if you look back uh central
banks and countries in general they have
a system for wholesale settlement that's
called rtgs real time growth settlement
system it has been implemented since
1980 so a lot of years ago and by now we
have almost like 80% of all the
countries with uh live rtgs systems but
it's a legacy infrastructure most
recently we have some central banks
implementing instant payment rails uh we
have a paks in Brazil UPI in India Cod
Mexico Fest and Singapore so many
instant payment systems but we are in
the middle of the journey we have uh by
now a little bit over 30% of the central
banks and counries implementing instant
payment rails and we are in the
beginning of the journey with a few
countries uh like Brazil with tracks we
have emble in Hong Kong we have a
Singapore experimenting a lot with yubin
and guardian you have a projects with
the RBA the the bank The Reserve Bank of
Australia with South Korea so and and
the Middle East as well so there are
definitely like some countries focusing
on putting together new rails which are
even compatible for broader tokenization
of the economy so we're going to see
these Trends colliding and public
blockchains and open source imp
Innovation contribution to this other
part of the of of the the story and at
the end of the day I think in the long
run you'll be seeing this networks
merging at at some point but it's it
takes some uh time for this to be
implemented on a global level we have
this first few countries that are
Implement those rails but it's a matter
of 10 15 years to have like a global
global coverage and we're just like
moving to this uh current phase of
blockchain based settlement systems so I
would like to invite the first few
panelists here I'm going to have a first
session on uh Trad fight going off on
fire so we're going to have Daniel
Marquez uh moderating Hart and Sophia
and with you as all participating and
I'm going to ask uh uh Daniel to to
introduce the panelist and introduce
himself as well thank you so much thanks
bro hello everyone my name is Dan arquez
I'm the co-founder of Kaki Ventures and
Venture executive at AI where we're
revolutionary
Capital markets using blockchain
technology um we have an amazing
panelist here today uh that have a wide
birth of experiences and backgrounds um
that we'll talk about the topic today
which is trafi going on defi uh we have
Sophia Lopez uh the founder and
president of cido uh we have Hart
Montgomery the CTO of Linux Foundation
decentral last trust and we have weit to
uh executive director at JP Morgan
I think I give a brief intro but I'd
love the for the panelists to introduce
themselves a little bit more on their
backgrounds and kind of what they bring
to the conversation today so we'll start
off with I guess wikii yeah thanks
everyone um Wiki to over here so um I'm
from JP Morgan in a unit what we call uh
kinexus digital payments I look at the
business architecture for um what we are
doing over there so essentially the use
of blockchain for payments we do a about
$1 billion uh in daily value of
transactions um I'll probably share more
during the session itself and yeah thank
you Sophia Lopez from one of the
founders of cido we're just um
celebrating seven years going into our
eighth year now um and we're web3
platform we work Prim really focused on
Enterprise so providing uh web3
Technologies at scale performant highly
regulated spaces we run all the open
source protocols that Enterprise wants
to use they're always adding new
technologies and prior to cido I had um
launched the IBM blockchain platform
with actually with uh Steve was
co-founder at cido with me so we brought
two years of learnings from like the
early days of uh Enterprise blockchain
back to 2015 into what Enterprises
really need a full stack of
plug-and-play components and
capabilities and that's what cido offers
hi everybody uh I'm Hart I work for the
Linux Foundation where I work as the CTO
of Linux Foundation decentralized trust
which incorporates a lot of hyperledger
and the Ed of the postquantum
cryptography Alliance um I've been at
the LF doing open source for about three
years before that I worked at Fujitsu
where I did blockchain and cryptography
research uh and before that I did a PhD
at Stanford and cryptography so I have a
background in Academia I guess awesome
thank you so much guys I guess my first
question is going to be for Wei could
you please expand uh and explain uh
Conexus which which was just rebranded
from Onyx uh and its role in global
payments and assets
organization yeah sure um so con Nexis
is really so maybe just a bit of a
background as well I mean JP Morgan we
are one of the largest uh US dollar
correspondent banks in the world so
essentially what we do is we help our
clients uh move funds uh when you are
doing so you know you could be banking
with any of the local banks in your
different countries if you are moving US
Dollars uh there's a very high chance
that ultimately is flowing through uh JP
Morgan So within JP Morgan itself what
we were doing is we wanted to look at
you know how can we better make use of
new technology uh essentially blockchain
technology and really the concept of
shed Ledger technology so what we did
was we built a blockchain based Payment
Systems uh we have been live since a
couple of years back we probably one of
the earliest Banks to be live um like
transacting with real value at scale um
using blockchain so um we are built on
Quorum um
yeah Sophia probably have a lot to say
about
that yeah yeah orad as well but yeah so
we be onum so we evm base um we allow
our clients to transact in US Dollars
Euros uh across major locations around
the world so one of the typical use
cases is a Treasurer um so he would have
accounts in say bank accounts in
Singapore in Hong Kong in London in New
York so all of these are in different
time time zones so if you look at the
more traditional way of doing treasury
management you have this concept of
follow the sun uh essentially everyone
works within the daytime and then they
hand it off to the next location uh in a
way at Sunset you know and the next
location continues on but with our
platform so essentially we allow for
real time uh 24x7 transactions so that
completely changed the model of how
treasurers think about payments because
now you have instant access to liquidity
anywhere around the world so that that
was quite interesting uh and another big
thing that we did was uh programmability
essentially allowing our clients to
deploy certain set of logic within our
platform itself um probably what you
would usually think of as smart
contracts the idea that clients can
write certain set of logic or code
deploy it within our system and then it
just runs as and when it's needed so
this ties in very much with the whole
24x7 kind of value proposition because
usually we think of it as like um you
know so on the system perspective we are
able to go 24x7 but from a operations
perspective um parties are always still
have to work so the idea around
automation is that parties are now able
to build those logic run it within the
system and then it can just continuously
run and yeah awesome thank you I think
so from I guess the Enterprise side
let's go maybe a little bit on the cbdc
side um sopia you know Koo has worked on
blockchain initiatives globally how does
ethereum based Solutions support cbdcs
like those in Brazil and Australia sure
sure well just add that Wii was at Mas
and I think you were part of the team
that first even came up with the term
cbdcs way back when so um yeah as Kido
uh provides as Enterprise gate
infrastructure we're actually working
with over 15 central banks and different
initiatives what's really interesting I
think uh from an ethereum lens because
we offer all the different protocol
options that enterprises might want to
use is really prominant focus on evm
based solutions for example Dre that um
Bruno was talking about chose besu a
number of years ago so now you have the
whole Drex ification of Brazil with
hundreds of banks involved and they're
all looking at evm and bestu for what
they're doing with asset tokenization
you mentioned also uh Daniel Australia
they also we've worked with them with a
number of projects going back years like
syndicated loans was the first project
with the Australian banks and central
banks um project Adam and then more
recently there was a a whole ecosystem
pilot 150 companies applied to
participate we were the basis of an
innovation platform using evm and
middleware such as Firefly from um Linux
Foundation that heart heart one of the
many code repos that sits uh under his
his prview there and it was really great
because they put out this call on on
this Innovation platform and said hey
retail wholesale cbdcs bring your ideas
Concepts there were very large
multinational players like um MasterCard
who participated there were all of the
banks partici ipated with really
interesting use cases but also some
startups actually launched their
businesses on the back of this pilot and
then the way were obviously when you're
dealing with the future of money central
banks are very thoughtful about how
they're doing their poc's and Pilots so
it's really great reports coming out of
some of these the analysis of the use
case a lot of times they might even have
workflows like Swift swift Phase 2 has a
lot of details for each of the use cases
they examine so I think ethereum is
we're seeing predominantly we're working
with some banks in the Middle East of
different parts of Asia like you know
Hong Kong hkma has done a number of um
pilots and work there other Southeast
Asian central banks um even European
were involved with the ECB uh digital
Euro trials with some exchanges and csds
and it's cross border obviously with
that you know Europe um trigger
mechanism different payments so there's
a lot of innovation happening on
ethereum and there's um a couple reasons
why my people really like the
programmability they want to do atomic
settlement on chain um and there have
been some tradeoffs when people were you
know maybe looking to go into production
in a highly regulated space they might
have had to do a trade-off where there
was like a notary or trusted party but
now with an announcement last week in a
new open source code-based Paladin you
can actually get programmable privacy in
a decentralized ethereum network so
that's very exciting for composable
finance institutional defi awesome thank
you I guess for you Hart um could you
introduce us a little bit more about the
Linux Foundation decentralized trust and
could you provide its overview
particularly in the context of evm
compatible environments absolutely so
who's here is familiar with Linux I hope
a lot of people who knows the Linux
foundation and how the Linux Foundation
Works some people okay great so the
Linux Foundation is designed to be a
neutral home for open-source code the
Linux Foundation solves the problem that
if you have multiple people or companies
or entities that want to come together
and develop in the open then they can do
that in the Linux Foundation even if
they don't fully trust one another so
it's it's a sort of concept of
decentralized development so I I usually
find that blockchain people you know
pick this up and and the need for it
relatively quickly um so we have over a
thousand projects in the Linux
Foundation at this point uh we keep
getting tons and tons of code you
probably know many of them like the
kernel uh maybe you know kubernetes if
you do any kind of cloud development or
deployments you know a lot of the
world's Telecom stack runs on LF
projects um more fun and interesting
things like uh the academy software
Foundation which does all of the uh
movie software editing it goes in
Hollywood um so you know we all probably
use you know dozens of projects in in
things we do every day and and don't
even know it um but we do have a number
of projects in the blockchain space and
particularly in the ethereum space and
uh we recently you know put together an
umbrella called the Linux Foundation
decentralized trust where we host you
know of all of our projects in
decentralized technology space um and
this is you know just for sort of
administration when at the LF we get a
lot of projects we like to group them
together um so we have a number of
projects here uh that are ethereum or
ethereum based um many of you may be
familiar with Basu which obviously sits
in the Linux Foundation um others we
have tools like uh Firefly Sophia
mentioned and cacti which are are very
frequently used in in various ethereum
applications U maybe some of you have
used web 3j to set up an ethereum
deployment um so we have lots of
interesting ethereum projects in the
Linux
Foundation um and and our goal is to be
that home for open neutral governance
awesome thank you and I guess back to
you
Sophia privacy is a critical concern in
evm environments with the Paladin
solution recently made open source at um
the Linux Foundation decentralized trust
how could Kido leverage this to address
privacy challenges and enhance
confidentiality in the
projects thanks I'm going to change the
answer a little bit to just how can
everyone leverage this because it's open
source open governance open development
I'm going to add on tag on to Hearts a
description I actually heard the Jim
zenin speak who leads the Linux
foundation and he said 80% of all the
open source code used in production by
Enterprises sits under the Linux
foundation so you know it's like a clean
licensing model and it's going to be an
open Community there's no cost to
participate so any developer here can
just contribute to it you know join the
discard pull the code down Etc so in
terms of a privacy at one thing I wanted
to start with is just privacy can mean
different things and like um maybe like
you know ethereum mainnet setting and
you know front running or what people
are trying to do there in an Enterprise
setting it's really over the years the
needs have been around confidentiality
so if I give Weeki a million dollars
Hart shouldn't be able to see any of
these details and then anonymity he
shouldn't even know that there was a
transaction between us and then history
masking where no one can sort of reverse
engineer the data the patterns to know
that you know their transaction
Providence or any of the details of the
entities Etc so then uh there's been
various techniques you know tesat is was
part of the Quorum codebase and we'd
work very closely with the Quorum team
it was a first evm production codebase
and a lot of Enterprises went into
production on that but there were um you
know some things that tesra couldn't do
like around private token transfers um
so this new code base um takes is like
really the next generation of tessora
and then add zero knowledge proofs and
then also adds um uh sort of a trusted
issuer model as well so there's
different patterns of deployment
depending on if you want to be like
fully decentralized or if you know you
could be really a network like a swift
who's moving into be still being a
trusted party but now bridging between
digital assets cbdcs and then that
business relationship or network might
you know H want to have someone in that
in that role so it's very very flexible
we did announce last week and um weeking
Hart were both there we uh were as Clyo
running project guardian wholesale
Network which had a number of banks
involved like City Standard Chartered
HSBC and asset managers like Schroeder
some of the Southeast Asian Banks as
well and it's a very exciting project
that that used the programmable privacy
um because they what they really wanted
to do was this the really the first
instantiation of institutional defi
where you have true composability and
composable finance at the Smart contract
level across tokenized cash the bonds in
repos and then funds in asset and wealth
management but then layering you know
being able to do that with the Privacy
which has eluded people or there's been
compromises that weren't acceptable to
some of these ecosystem projects we work
with like for example you know Drex in
Brazil this is an example of one Central
Bank we've worked with others as well
they say hey if our nodes are down we
still want transaction finality and we
don't want to be playing the special
Trust trusted issuer role so um I
encourage everyone who's technical to
take a look at Paladin or you know come
talk to us afterwards but um there'll be
a lot of We did an inperson workshop
last week and different workshops coming
to you and webinars and things to just
Kickstart um more involvement we've had
great input from Partners like like
Weeki JPM and others over the last six
months just in terms of um forming the
community and bringing it Forward great
thank you and uh I'll send this over to
you Wei so so if you have briefly
mentioned that you're actually part were
part of the monetary authority of
Singapore uh I'm curious from your
previous experience there how do you see
cbdcs evolving and what role would evm
Solutions play as part of those core
taxs for these digital currencies got it
so um yeah maybe just quick history so I
used to be at the mer authority of
Singapore um I was there for about six
years uh leading cbdc projects so we
probably one of the earlier central
banks to be working on cbdcs uh back in
2016 started working with Kido um and
lots of different partners back then um
so I was also working on project damba
at the B Innovation Hub that was on
multic cbdc I do feel that um you know
ultimately when we talk about blockchain
why why is it so interesting for us um
because from a public ethereum
perspective the value is probably much
clearer so why are Enterprises
interested in blockchain uh a large part
of it is really in terms of how
governance actually works so if you
think about multic cbdcs for example or
generally any multicurrency platform if
you have currency issued by individual
parties so cbdc is probably the easiest
to explain you have Sing dollar issued
by masas you have um you know Australian
dollar issued by the Reserve Bank of
Australia so how do they actually issue
on a common platform now in a more
traditional infrastructure you have to
have a single stack essentially there's
a single platform and you always have
this question who owns and operate the
platform Now blockchain is really
interesting for us because it kinds of
provide a technical solution to this
governance problem the ability for us to
actually run it as a multi-party shed
Ledger that to me is the most
interesting part of it so um there are a
lot of other projects that we are
continuing to pursue one of it is just
generally within the banks now we are
also starting to see very much like what
you know within the public ethereum
where you see value the idea that anyone
could be developing applications
applications can very similarly interact
with each other we are seeing the same
within Enterprise um blockchain itself
so the idea that you know from a JP
Morgan perspective we provide payment
services or we are working with part to
provide payment services we could have
another bank doing security settlement
how could we actually deploy that on a
common platform um the various different
applications being able to interact with
each other that allow us to do really
cool things like DVP is really just a
start but what if I am trying to buy a
Securities in US dollars but I I don't
have US dollars I only have Euros could
I do essentially what is like a DVP VP
uh exchange my Euros for US Dollars and
then using that US dollars to buy those
Securities all in a single Atomic
transaction so I think that is actually
getting a lot of interest from an
Enterprise perspective because we see
that this is going to allow for much
more seamless transaction processing and
also help to reduce settlement RIS as
well okay thank you heart privacy is a
significant uh concern in the evm
environments uh particularly for
institutional use through the work that
you're doing at the Linux Foundation
decentralized trust could you discuss
the specific challenges related to
maintaining privacy and high throughput
environments and ensuring composability
while preserving data
confidentiality absolutely Enterprises
and really everyone when they want a
blockchain system they want it all right
they want privacy they want security
they want scal ability they want
decentralization um many of you have
probably heard of the blockchain trialo
which says you can't have all of these
at once um but we do see a push where
people say hey if you can give me this
privacy model and you can give me this
level of performance I can run this in a
decentralized way on on a blockchain and
I think that's really exciting so we've
seen a lot of advancements uh and in
things like ZK proving systems which are
really getting us closer and closer sir
if any of you are out there working on
that that's fantastic I'm really excited
about all the work going on there um but
really it comes down to for for
businesses and finance um really
defining the Privacy model and a lot of
businesses and and Enterprises don't
really know what they want in terms of
privacy they say they want privacy um
but you have to get them to Define it uh
and once you get them to Define it then
you can start applying you know
cryptographic techniques um and you know
I think zkp techniques are are going to
eventually sort of be the dominant U
technique people use for privacy in the
future great thank you uh
Wiki JP Morgan has been involved in
projects like project guardian and uh
Global layer 1 how do you see blockchain
specifically evm unlocking innovative
business models and enhancing efficiency
in financial service you mentioned it a
little bit at the end of your answer but
maybe you can expand on that yeah so um
back back to this idea you know where I
talk about a much more integrated
Financial ecosystem now um if we were to
have that we we need to essentially have
a blockchain platform that all the banks
are able to deploy their applications on
now of course in a very Ideal World you
would say there's public ethereum why
don't Banks just use public ethereum um
we do continue to face some of these
governance considerations because from A
bank's perspective um you know anytime
we are trying to use any technology just
even as a very simple example if you
were to try to use cloud services um
from a regulator perspective you'll ask
us around questions around like
Outsourcing um who are you Outsourcing
to who is actually who's going to uh
enforce the SLA what is the kind of
recovery time that they are uh
guaranteeing you so those are some of
the questions and then there's also all
the other questions relating to
technology risk management slas so of
course from a public ethereum
perspective most of you will probably
think like oh those questions are
probably not so relevant but from an
Enterprise blockchain perspective those
questions are very relevant to us
because we can only use the platform if
we are able to answer those questions um
so in the absence of being able to
answer those questions using public
ethereum for example um what we are
trying to do is essentially Banks coming
together to say hey why don't we operate
a private instance of
you know something like a ethereum that
we can then all use and we can then all
deploy our applications on so from our
perspective the idea is really a a
blockchain that is operated by financial
institutions for financial institutions
um definitely is not going to be as open
as public ethereum but we do think that
there's a middle ground where
essentially you know with a right set of
rule books with a right set of
onboarding criteria it can still be open
and accessible to all banks are able to
fulfill the minimum criteria so that to
us is probably the best that we can push
in terms of having an open and
accessible blockchain Network so um just
to name the project that's actually what
the banks are working on uh called
Global layer one essentially trying to
build and operate a blockchain network
that we are able to use awesome thank
you and Sophia cloud has been
contributing to initiatives like the um
like project guardian to leverage D5
principles to for crossb transactions
and ities can you expand on
that yeah and I maybe I'll do an
advertisement for the next panel because
I might we might be transitioning to
them I think Bruno had a good slide
where he showed there's new Financial
networks that are being built and you
know global global layer one or this
Guardian wholesale Network there are
examples of those um and there's you
know brand new types of networks there's
people like Swift who've done we ran
over 38 banks that they connected cross
border with asset and cash networks over
you know four different use cases um for
FX and trade finance and DVP so there's
a lot of interesting work happening on
the network side or you see payment
processors like MasterCard was also on
on Bruno slide then you also see you
know Banks like JP Morgan and others
looking at asset tokenization and and
they just want to be able to launch
their assets at all these different
types of new networks and really get
liquidity you get the global uniqueness
with ethereum obviously with the the
asset types and you can get this
composability even across networks so
what's interesting in the next panel we
talk about more is there's these new
unified Ledger approaches like the bank
of international settlements is is
leading and there's one in production
called emridge in this region of the
world that's been very exciting there's
private initiatives like paror which J
which JP Morgan Wei mentioned who are
also trying to do like sort of unified
Ledger for for FX and then you have many
other Varian so I do think composability
across these networks because there's
different reasons and motivations for
different geographies or um different
groups to come together but you still
need that open interoperable
composability across all of those so I
think it is a very exciting time uh for
ethereum and you know you have all the
way from the m0 M1 you know like future
of money is changing and the countries
who do that well and faster they're
going to have a competitive Advantage
versus the ones who uh stay behind so I
think it's going to be a very Dynamic
space in the next you know years awesome
um I think just to wrap it up I want to
like shift a little bit towards the
future so Hart you mentioned that you
also guys also are working on uh uh
Quantum proof cryptography and future
proofing the evm uh with the
advancements in Quantum Computing
there's a growing focus on developing
Quantum resistant cryptographic methods
from your perspective how would you see
Quantum proof cryptography shaping the
future of evm based platforms and what
steps can the industry take to ensure
long-term ensure long-term security
yeah this is a great question um we
don't know when quantum computers are
going to be able to do things like
Factor RS say 2048 um I don't think
there are any Quantum physicists in the
room maybe someone will be here
and but um you know so so I'm not a
physicist so I don't know either um but
the immediate thing to do is uh if if
you're storing data on a blockchain in
an encrypted form you need to think
about taking action soon has anyone
heard of this Harvest now decrypt later
problem that that goes in some people
that's great so the basic idea is it's
on the internet and especially on a
blockchain if you're sending you know
encrypted data across the internet or or
storing it on a blockchain someone is
recording that and it's it's around
forever right um particularly on a
blockchain right you know this isn't a
super common uh public ethereum
application because you know space is
expensive but particularly in more
Enterprise or Finance settings people
are willing to post encrypted uh
information on blockchains and in this
case well you know if you have data on a
blockchain right and someone comes along
10 years later with a quantum computer
and that data is encrypted with you know
a Quantum insecure crypto system which
if you put it on the blockchain today
you know you're probably using some step
that's Quantum insecure uh then they can
decrypt that data right and if you
needed that data to be secure for say 10
years or longer you have a problem right
so the most immediate thing to do for
Quantum Security is to assess if you're
posting any encrypted data on chain or
sending it across the internet in any
kind of you know way that uses public
key cryptography uh and if you are think
about how long you need that data to be
secure when you think a quantum computer
might be around and and adjust your uh
your crypto systems to something
postquantum accordingly from the evm you
know the evm itself doesn't use any
encrypted data right you know the big
thing is is digital signatures um so
there's already you know a relatively
flexible signature protocol uh in in the
evm specs so that's great um but we will
need to to transition to postquantum
signatures and that will be a little bit
frustrating because the uh the key and
the signature sizes can be substantially
larger something like 8 to 10 times um
so we're going to have to think about
that with respect to you know available
space on a
blockchain thank you so much I think
that wraps up our panel uh I'll hand it
off to Bruno to introduce the next panel
thank you guys so
much thanks and we'll be around if you
have any
[Applause]
questions amazing thank you guys was an
excellent first panel uh for the next
one I'm going to highlight some case
studies some some companies that are
already building these nection rails
that are blockchain based and evm
compatible so I'm going to call Susanna
uh from uh which the the leader of
blockchain strategy for world food food
program at the United Nations to
moderate the panel uh also abinav from
parture which one one of the companies
that was mentioned during the the first
panel also ital Borat which uh the the
lead uh product lead at bis the bank for
international settlement in Hong Kong
has been uh spearheading many projects
there with a lot of banks and central
banks and Bruno mon as well from
interbank a Brazilian bank that's been
working around Solutions blockchain B
Solutions on top of DX the Brazilian
cbdc
okay so hello everyone um I will start
by presenting myself very fast uh and
say a few words that I think are
relevant uh as Bruno said I work at wfp
un uh working as blockchain lead uh I
will not talk about that but if you want
to see uh more about the work that we do
like dispersing money for vulnerable
population tracked by blockchain uh
there is a panel there's a session on
Friday and that I will speak and I hope
hope you'll be there um but I want to
talk a bit about the work that I was
doing before this work um I joined a wfp
3 years ago before I was working for 14
years on brazilan Development Bank uh
and there we created um in 2017 we were
exploring um we were launching a token
to track um the disbursements of uh the
bank uh in that time um it was not the
people in the bank was not conf able uh
on using uh public ethereum we in 2017
right um and then we decided to create
as a Development Bank we also decided to
create a a Brazilian Network and what
what I want to show you is that at that
time Enterprise blockchain was really
really strong and there was a a kind of
a huge discussion with the community
which uh platform should be used uh and
there was a huge lob for using no
etheral ones uh but at that time we
would already think we we are already
thinking that it would make sense to us
to be in open source to be like in a
public permissionless network because we
would imine that uh there these things
that we are discussing today are
relevant so we would imagine that we
want to be compatible uh with uh the
things that are we are discussing today
and all the development that uh the eum
community is doing and maybe in the
future we would maybe even be in
ethereum again so so I'm very happy that
we made that decision uh the same
decision was actually made uh by the
Brazilian Central Bank as well uh so
both networks are now uh created uh on
Bess um that's also Linux Foundation uh
and that's yeah I feel like very
connected with this panel because of
this uh having said that I stopped
talking and I asking uh so ital uh Bruno
uh and Abby uh please like two C of to
introduce yourself my name is ital Batu
I work at the bis uh bis is the bank uh
for international settlements it's the
bank for the central banks people call
like that um I came from the web3 space
um and um uh I joined it recently a year
and a half ago uh the bis and I'm
Enthusiast uh on blockchain and
decentralized identity yeah okay uh my
name is Bruno monise I'm a blockchain
enger at inter inter is one of the most
uh Innovative banks in the Brazil and we
work with uh a big super app that have
like shop e-commerce and nonfinancial
apps it's a lot of stuffs we launch it
as social media in the the the same app
so uh we strongly believe in the
vitalics pathway you know the financial
and nonfinancial apps so we we're trying
to build the stuffs and we are also
working with the uh some International
uh initiatives on cbdcs and on the DRS
you know someone here heard about dra
and know what is the
Drax so you definitely need to to know
more about this stuff if you're looking
to to build onchain stuffs you
definitely need to to meet the Brazilian
cbdc project uh we are doing a
incredible framework for for build on
chain stuffs
here yeah hi good afternoon I'm abinav I
lead The Client Solutions and pre-sales
for part year I think previous panel
actually talked about part year a lot I
think what we do is fundamentally we
provide a shared Ledger infrastructure
for banks to be able to do realtime
payments and settlement and it can be
for any type of payment it can be for a
commercial payment it can be for FX
payment or for a security settlement so
I think that's what we do uh from a
background perspective I'm not
technologist like web3 I've been always
working with the traditional Banks I've
been a kind of a payment Enthusiast uh
work with those to figure out how we can
transform their payment Journey for the
banks and that's from where I came from
and then I decided to join partyer
because I see that we can do actually
disrupt the payments
business amazing thank you so much uh
you start with Italo uh so Italo can you
explain uh first of all uh what bis
Innovation Hub is uh what projects you
are working there uh or you are being
involved with in the past uh and how it
is advancing the infrastructure of
payments okay so like I said the bis is
the bank for the Central Bank it is an
institution that was created by the
central banks um after the world war and
um it is um maintained by more than 63
um uh central banks around the world um
and a few years ago five years ago to be
more exact um uh they decided to launch
this um um initiative The Innovation Hub
um so they launched um six and six uh um
uh centers around the world um uh I'm
working in the one uh in Hong Kong um
and basically what it does is to
experiment um um new
technologies um and deliver that as a
public good for the the central banks
all the projects are we try to keep them
uh in the experimental uh phase so they
are usually PCS and
prototypes um and but you'll see if you
read the reports and it's more than 40
Projects so far
um I mean between all the the centers um
you see a lot of uh Concepts from the
the the defi space web3 um blockchain um
DT Technologies right um you see a lot
of that but always from the perspective
um adding the the
regulations um uh Stronger governance in
everything so um it's interesting to to
take a look uh um and a lot of them
focusing on
cbdcs um and that's what I do also in
the Hong Kong Center so there are
projects like Dynamo Ambridge um um uh
Genesis um safe uh aperta all of them
using uh new technologies for the
central banks thanks okay um so ABI uh
please uh can you uh provide an overview
about uh the company ptio M show and how
it emerged from project ubin uh it's
good idea to explain the project as well
of course uh and it would be nice if you
could comment how it relates with uh the
B yeah so so I think Italo mentioned
about the fact is that from a central
bank perspective they do lot of projects
and I think for right reason for
industry to move and that's where kind
of part year was formed part year
Genesis is Project Oben uh this is a
central bank of Singapore initiative we
started way back in 2016 uh where they
want to kind of see assess the
blockchain technology on how it can
solve the inefficiencies with the crossb
payment space and they did variety of
use cases around that whether it's for
FX payments Securities and everything
else and this whole project Journey went
for around 5 years and when it was done
with over 20 plus financial institution
uh everybody liked the idea but somebody
has to commercialize it being a central
bank they can't commercialize it and
that's where tamask which is a Sovereign
wealth fund of Singapore JP Morgan and
DBS decided to commercialize it and in
2021 October is that's where the partyer
was formed or born right uh now we are
we are business live I think it is no
more in the POC or experimentation stage
uh we have Pro we went live last year
November and till date we have processed
more than 1 billion worth value of
transaction it is still a small scale
but I think being a blockchain
infrastructure it is still a good to
start with I think so and we are
processing uh real um trans transactions
right and I think fundamentally from our
perspective what we want to provide is a
better infrastructure to the banks right
typically if you see right now the whole
money movement happens is every Bank
have their own siloed Ledger and the
money moves very sequentially across
different blockchain across different
ledgers and that is where the the the
issue lies in terms of cost and speed
that is what we are trying to solve with
bringing a shared Ledger infrastructure
second key paino what we are trying to
solve always is right now when the money
movement happens it it is it is
happening in a very discrete first the
information moves and then the value
moves how we can have a unified
messaging and settlement infrastructure
which will helps to avoid all the
reconciliation which needs to be done
across different financial
institutions um and and finally is that
the current Banks infrastructure being
so Legacy this is only so much you can
do with that you can't innovate much and
I think Vicki talked about some new
instruments whether it is F swaps in F
swaps repos I think those instruments
you need to build you need to kind of
use a better infrastructure and this is
where kind of partier comes in and bring
is all those Technologies uh element to
it uh I think three four things I want
to just call it out broadly is what is
something which I see my clients
specifically are very interested is
about four things one is digital um
second is what they call about
programmable uh third they talk about
multi-asset and fourth they talk about
shared liser and I'll just spend a
minute about each each of them what does
it mean so when we say digital right I
think we talked about multiple digital
assets are coming in right now right
whether it's tokenized bonds tokenized
money market funds everything is there
but there is a need for a digital cash
you know you need digital cash to be
able to settle instantly and automic
those those digital assets and this is
where kind of partyer kind of brings in
the whole angle of tokenizing cash on
chain using the commercial bank money
you know and and if you see right now
most of the wholesale institutions the
wholesale banking works on Commercial
Bank money so that's what is a digital
is second programmability I think Vicki
talked about that is something which is
very very exciting because we see new
use cases coming around that
specifically for corporates on how they
can manage their cash concentration
structures which is move which is
basically moving more on a realtime base
versus end of day movement U that second
third is multi asset I think this is
where the global liquidity pool comes
into play because now with this the the
market players have an option to choose
which asset they want to use to settle
their P payment obligation and not
dependent on the financial Market
infrastructure operating hours or the
settlement Cycles so this is where it
becomes a single pool of liquidity and
finally the shared Leisure I think we
want to be on a shared layered
infrastructure which helps to kind of
settle
instantly thank you okay um so coming
now to Bruno uh and talking about
collaboration um I like you you talk
about uh the Dr uh so I wanted to uh
that you explain uh that interbank um
you are involved with the Brazilian
Central Bank that uh directs but also
with the Hong Kong monetary Authority
right um in the project called Ensemble
right so yeah please explain the project
uh and also um explain how do you think
this collaborations shape the future of
cbdc uh especially regarding crossboard
interoperability and real time set Els
okay um first I'm going to explain a
little bit about the the Drax the
Brazilian cbdc and then uh how how the
the system connect to the symble and the
all those things first the Brazilian
cbdc is the ethereum private Network so
we have like 16 participants and every
institution need to run a node so it's a
decentralized uh one it's not a I know
when when I say decentralized Network in
ethereum cbdc everyone I got the
attention of the everyone here uh but
okay uh so we have the smart settlement
layer and looks like ethereum uh and
then we need to build the protocols and
the core assets the wholesale uh
currency the retail currency and all
those stuffs and we are building in
smart contracts and for now we are doing
we are dealing with the private solution
because uh ethereum is so transparent
and we need private for the users to you
know uh the the bank system uh need to
protect the users against uh you know if
I have your bank account I don't know uh
Al transactions that you have done so we
need to to do those things on chain and
for now Drex is dealing with those uh
those
challenges and the assemble project it's
uh Innovative initiative to to test uh
infrastructure for the financial market
and imagine that we have we're going to
have different cbdcs and for now we have
the the opportunity to reshape the the
the paths to the business workflows and
for the the technology because for for
now we have a lot of Standards but uh in
a in a national uh in the National
infrastructure we already have a lot of
different systems and a lot of uh
Payment Systems it's it's confused and
when you go like to an international
environment it's more complex than that
okay we have standards but we don't have
like digital native standards and now we
having the the opportunity to to shape
those things and with uh with the hkma
and the
assemble project we are we are going to
to test the trade Finance business cycle
you know the trade Finance is like when
you you are buying or selling a
commodity and the seller and when when I
sell some commodity uh I want the money
right now you know the I already made a
ship so you're going to receive by 3 to
n months and but you you are buying
you're only one to to pay when the you
know the the
commodity uh got delivered to to your
your country so the trade Finance is
like a it's when a a bank is going to to
pay the the seller to receive the to to
send the the commodity and then he he's
just financing the the whole system and
providing liquidity so we have a chance
to increase the liquidity and also to
use eot and a lot of connections to make
the system work better you know because
uh you you don't need to pay all the the
the commodity when you're when you're in
the first day we can just track the ship
and when the ship advance I can pay and
you know do those things all on chain
and using this trust machine to run all
the cycle and assemble is more about it
it's a proof of concept uh project so
we're not doing with a we we are trying
to create something that is going to
beat the the prodution but we're dealing
with uh with more academic research
yes thank you uh so coming back to you
italu um can you explain a bit more like
what are the insights that have emerged
from the projects to facilitate
crossborder payments um using multi cbdc
platforms and how it is reshaping
crossborder uh payments yeah um usually
in crossborder the way things uh money
moves right you need institutions that
have um um bank accounts with each other
around the world so if you want to
transact uh between countries um uh
there is always um correspondent bank we
call uh which has these accounts in both
countries of course they do a lot of
Services also like checking uh the
reason for that transaction and all the
documents that are surrounding that like
invoices and uh what is the the type of
transaction to avoid uh money laundering
and and uh terrorism actions right uh so
sometimes we forget that um um and and
usually if you live in a country um um
where the the the currency has liquidity
with other pairs that you you want to
transact it's easy because um uh it's
more instant you have more options of
correspondent banks that will deal with
this
transactions um uh but if you are in a
country a small country and you want to
do the same it will be a nightmare you
you you spend a lot of time uh you can
have platforms like paral that help that
but I mean I I imagine you have a lot of
uh cenes but there will be countries
where you you are not there right and
with the cbdc in the cross border um
what happens is uh we don't know yet how
it will behave right but if you have a
tokenized version of the the cbdc and
then comes a difference from the the the
money from the banks I don't want to
spend much time but the the the the cbdc
is considered a legal tender like like
uh cash like Bank notes uh different
from the money that is in in your
balance in your account in the bank that
is uh we call M1
um and uh this is something good that
the banks do because you can have more
mu1 in the market and it brings
liquidity but at the same time if you
want to achieve the the settlement the
the settlement finality we call in a
transaction you need to wait for the end
of the day in one country when the rtgs
of that uh country that jurisdictions um
updates the balance of each one of these
commercial Banks and and this is
something that uh even if you see the
the the money transacting um in a Swift
uh uh transaction for example um uh they
wait for this time to to guarantee the
settlement right and if you go to higher
values you you need to to be careful
with that and then you you need more
Trust on the system that you are using
um and with the cbdcs what will happen
is um it doesn't matter if it's in a
single Ledger uh or if it it will be
multiple ledgers using mechanisms to
like um for example htlc to lock some
some amount here and and uh Implement um
um an atomic settlement in all the the
networks um what really matter is that
you will have atomicity and uh probably
to be um not instantaneous but uh I mean
in a in seconds compared to what happens
today we have a few servic that do that
um um if you go to wise and partial you
can access services that will be instant
uh but you are relying and trusting in
their bank accounts with the banks that
they are using so it doesn't mean that
it's um um it's a bit different from the
cbdc um conceptually uh and it affects
at the end uh all the the ecosystem yeah
thank you so I want to go to evm now um
a bit more technical I want to uh Paro
um understand how Paro is utilizing VM
based infrastructure to unlock
innovation in multicurrency crossborder
payments particularly in areas like
liquidity Management in real time
settlements yeah uh thank you I think
before I just want to kind of finish
this your thoughts what you said about I
think clearly cbdc come as the most
safest settlement asset and I think this
is where I don't think so this more of a
technology problem it is more about how
central banks sees it in terms of their
access policies you know we still have a
challenge of anybody in off institution
be able to hold a domestic cbdc of other
so I think I think we need to solve that
as well but clearly what I see is the
commercial bank money and central bank
money they have to be there and that's
where the entire monetary framework is
working on and there are specific use
cases where the need for a central bank
money as well so so so I think so that's
why I going call it out uh but I think
in terms of some of the uh use cases uh
I want to talk about but before I take a
step back on we are dealing with with
banks you know and in the last panel
there was a discussion around when banks
are so particular about the kycs and
regulations and compliance so so the way
what we have done is we first of all
Focus some time to build a base
infrastructure that helps to kind of
tick off these boxes you know uh we use
uh Korum I think um in the last panel
Vicki also talked about Korum I think
that helps to kind of been designed to
support a more of a private permission
Network so which works for us and it
also gives an ability for us to run
partition networks for each of the big
Banks who provide liquidity to their
known participants so that kind of takes
a box from from a governance standpoint
um second key thing was privacy I think
we spoke a lot about the Privacy so I'll
not go deep dive into that we discuss
about that uh the third key thing is
settlement finality you know uh from A
bank's perspective it was very key to
see how do we get a deterministic
finality and not a probabil uh ity right
so that is where uh that is where we are
using uh the the protocol uh consensus
protocol which is ibft that helps to
give us a deterministic finality um on
our side and finally is access and
governance you know and that is where um
using ethereum evm technology it helps
to kind of do that with Korum um that
has been kind of designed to support a
permission mode capability so I think
this is where we kind of send up a good
amount of time at least year or so to
build the platform as well as the rule
book and then we start building the
products around that so the first one
was the uh crossborder payment um I
think the way we have done is we use the
smart contracts to automate the entire
orchestration of the crossb payment
workflow uh and that what we have done
with embedded prevalidation and
pre-screening you know and what does it
mean from A bank's perspective it it
gives them a certainty because it go
through the entire prevalidation and
pre-screening for first before the
settlement happens which becomes very
immutable in state so so this is what we
have done the entire orchestration
around that and we also kind of done a
build a capability called multi-
settlement Bank concept which helps to
kind of chain series of payments which
are very earlier sequential basically
we're going to chain it and make it very
SLE Atomic nature so so this is kind of
a use case we have done from a
crossborder payment use case um second
was on the FX payment versus payment I
think this is where uh the banks very
keen to work with us this is uh if you
see right now there is no instruments
which kind of support a PVP Arrangement
yes CLS which is there but they are not
actually true PVP um they have their own
still their own settlement Cycles but
this is where gets more excited uh for
emerging market currencies where you can
settle on a PVP basis um and that helps
to kind of unlock your collateral to be
do Deploy on a better way so I think
this is some of the ones which we have
done and I can go go on and on but yeah
yeah thank you amazing um so coming to
tokenization to you Bruno um so
tokenization has been called the
revolution for banks uh and you love DRS
uh that's amazing project so with tracks
uh focus on tokenized assets uh like
public bonds and real estate how does
interbank plans to integrate tokenized
assets into its services and what
benefits could this brings for retail
retail customers and institutional
investors yes great um because the we
have like two two problems with the
democratization of the finance and the
first one I think is the tooling uh you
you don't the users don't have the tool
to know uh manage their their funds or
have access to different products and
the tokenization uh can um can you know
by tokenization we can create new
product and made the ones that already
exist even cheaper to to the the client
and having a settlement layer a smart
settlement layer where we can create
official deposits and official digital
products like uh credit like uh the the
ID of your car or maybe the the property
rights of your own house and those
things on on a chain that the central
bank and the whole system integrate with
you you're going to create a lot of
products but like like defi imagine we
can bring defi to reward assets using uh
the uh the official cbdc but the second
phase is like uh okay now we have the
tools we can bring a lot of things from
defi but the tool is just so weird to
use and in Defi and the public
blockchains we are having this issue uh
uh the experience is so fragmented and
it's hard to use uh crypto product
products it's getting easier yes uh you
know it's getting even better we have a
lot of products that integrate with uh
different chains and different products
and in the the financial landscape we
also have th those problems we have a
lot of products but the tooling is
difficult and this is where inter comes
and we we have a a important super app
and we saw the the P ful the power of
integrate non-financial apps to
financial apps and how to to Really
create value to the the clients because
for for now you can use your bank
account to access investment not only in
a free way but in a easy way because you
have a intellig artificial intelligent
agent that can understand your expenses
and understand what what you can do and
what you can't do and how can I achieve
my goals uh if I want to buy a new new
house how can I do those things and this
is not a it it's something that digital
tokenization can uh improve but the user
experience is something that we can do
with blockchain and without blockchain
but with blockchain is
better amazing um so yeah continuing on
tokenization uh to you Ito now we want
to know about a bit more about bis how
bis is collaborating with the home Kong
monetary Authority uh on the initiatives
like project and Sample um and
um and how it will enable interbank
settlement of toiz assets okay so um the
Hong Kong Center is independent from
hkma we are in the same building in Hong
Kong a beautiful building um so we we
cross um uh with with the the team from
the hkma all the time um so there is
this this proximity um all the the
projects that we have there um of course
they they are aligned they know what we
are executing we discuss with them um
but in the project assemble the
participation of the bis is very minimal
we are only part of the um uh
architecture community that they build
um just adding it similar to draxx they
have multiple projects as well um it's
not only the the the international trade
um and um um yeah they explore the
tokenization of Bones and um also in the
crossborder scenario um with green bones
specifically they try that um but yeah
many other uh types of of um uh
settlements with uh not only payments
but uh with reward assets uh in the
middle yeah amazing I mean I still have
lots of questions but I don't have time
so we need to finish now and come back
to you thank you thank
[Applause]
you hello perfect thank you everyone for
the a great panel as well shifting gears
here I think we talked a lot about cbdcs
financial institutions permission rails
and how this more regulated environment
is evolving right but uh for last last
panel we're going to invite some
protocol some uh solutions that are
building on top of public blockchains so
we're going to uh double click on this
trans uh transition kind of understand
uh if there's a path uh from permission
to permissionless
so I'm going to invite uh the the panels
the panelists here that will cover this
topic so kinan will be the mon theator
uh please feel free uh also Thiago from
tansi will be joining us uh during the
discussions luuka kiv from yeah perfect
from open Zepp will also be here and uh
Shima from uh plume Network so please
feel free and and if you guys can uh
start the panel with around Ju part
thank you so much guys have fun thank
you so much Bruno always uh about saving
the best for the last I know energy
levels might a bit low so it's our job
to deliver not just content but a bit of
spice in it uh first and foremost we'll
start we'll get the standard stuff out
of the way of introductions uh I'll go
first and then I'll ask the panelists to
give a one minute introduction of
themselves um and also ask them a very
interesting question so be besides
introducing yourself tell us what is the
first cryptocurrency token that you
bought for yourself okay so you can
think about that recall the memory I'll
go first um so my name is chinnan I lead
seison Capital we are one of the few
Asian financial institutions that have
set up a dedicated digital asset
investing arm so we can invest not just
in equity stuff but we can actually
directly invest in digital assets
invested more than 50 early stage
companies globally and we also have a
fun of funds mandate uh the reason why
I'm moderating this panel other than
having multiple friendly faces here um
It's really because this divide between
permissionless and permission is
something that's really important right
as we think about how do we scale how do
we get institutions on board so I'm
super excited um to get folks to come on
board um and maybe the the the CL
clarification for that it's what's the
first token that you bought for I mean
not not for gas right I think that would
be interesting for me it was uh actually
actually XC Infinity uh this was in
early 2020s so game five was actually
what brought me uh into into web tree
over to you
go hi guys uh Jim thank you so my name
is Thiago I'm one of the co-founders of
tansy network um and I'm currently
heading tensi
Foundation uh so tensy is a
decentralized uh protocol for fast
tracking the launching of fully
decentralized uh n networks uh this is
very generic I know but actually what we
do uh our product is pretty much like a
fully decentralized layer one uh you can
think of teni uh as um a Ras provider
but the the fundamental very fundamental
difference between what we do and Ras
traditional Ras provide is uh we offer
uh fully uh a fully decentralized and
permissionless way right soens is a
protocol uh that leverages rest assets
to ensure the security for this
decentralized network so oh by the way
the token right so funny enough the
first token I ever bought was not
Bitcoin uh and was funny also to hear
from you that was not Bitcoin uh I
bought Solana so I used to do uh I used
to work in a hedge fund before I did
that 10 years in my life um and uh I
started to to my career in crypto
actually working with some research in
this hedge fund right and uh that was
pretty much in the defi summer and um I
I needed to make the the defi course
right uh and back then the the gas fees
are were pretty pretty um expensive so
and Solana was starting to to get some
traction uh and I saw another ecosystem
which was very very interesting and a
lot of different applications was were
emerging there and was very cheap so my
course would be way cheaper there so of
course nowadays we have a bunch of
solutions that try to to mitigate the
the r the the cost fluctuations right
that's actually one of the core features
that t enable as well in our
decentralized networks uh but yeah that
was the the very first one and then I
bought some tokens in the in the salana
ecosystem very cool you should be very
happy in the past 12 months all right to
you yeah thanks uh so yeah my name is
Luca I did our EX system development
efforts at open Zeppelin we build
developer libraries and tooling maybe
some of you have already imported open
Zeppelin contracts I think today I was
just checking we've passed 7.5 trillion
in total value transferred uh from
people that use open zein contracts
which is a statement of of course the
scale of ethereum and what has happened
but obviously the trust that people put
into our libraries uh we've built a lot
of develop developer tooling uh and we
also do security audits uh in the space
we recently audited uniswap V4 which has
some interesting properties for for
trafi um and yeah I think I mean yeah it
was definitely eeper my first token but
that's not memorable I think the first
one that I really remember was Dogecoin
so yeah
that's
awesome um hi everyone this is Shuki I'm
I'm the chief strategy officer at PL
Network so uh prior to joining the team
here I was the CMO and the founding team
member of
polyhedra uh so polyhedra is basically
my first crypto project and I bought um
Bitcoin as my first crypto currency and
also the second one is Solana because we
were talking to salana Foundation for
the Z Bridge integration and I try to
figure out what happened why it was like
so hard to integrate but yeah it was the
second currency uh so about plume we are
the r Focus uh blockchain and we combine
RW assets on chain with the D5
strategies and it's easier for uh the
retail users and the Global Investors to
access to more uh iing you know
investment pro products uh from try work
world yeah got it so none of us bought
Eve so I think that's the end of the pan
no I'm kidding all right so so so let's
let's let's get to the the meat of this
right and I think before we get into the
Technologies and products which I'm
which I'm sure you guys have much to
share let's start off with something a
bit more meta a bit more philosophical
we have permission lists chains tvls
that have grown to a $3 trillion market
cap and then we have the rise of these
permission chains that are happening we
just has heard from the likes of Drax
from layer one network and all
directionally where do you think we're
hided are we hided towards the you know
one taking over the other are we heading
towards both coexisting side by side
relatively same size kind of where will
we
be so that's a good question uh I think
we I mean in maybe I'm biased to to
answer that uh considering that we are
doing a lot of work in the app chain
space at teni so uh I think we are
leading to to this uh multi-chain world
that we always uh kind of uh uh dream
and spoke of but in a very in a way more
integrated way right so today uh we are
very sophisticated in aggregation layers
there are uh pumping the bridging and in
general messaging protocols I think
that's uh strong stronger than ever um
and also I think that's very important
to mention the that we probably going to
see a way more institutionalized
uh crypto Market going forward right
which uh might change U fundamentally
many many things um but uh probably is
going to be giving more uh making the
market a little bit more rational right
uh I think we finally going to have
models investment models uh and me being
X ex straty guy I I pretty like it but
uh yeah these are two of the the main
the main Visions I have from the the
next short
term yeah so uh for plume side we've
been seeing a lot of uh uh interesting
institutional moves because we got a lot
of we're actually talking to a lot of
people in the United States in Singapore
in Hong Kong and we noticed that a lot
of uh I say institutional Partners think
of us as the distribution channels and
also you know some for some permission
blockchain like with the fully kyc one
they're using us as one of the
distribution Channel using our tool
called Skylink it's basically passing
the yields back to the blockchain users
uh with the uh with the more uh
interoperable way using the bridge using
the interoperability uh relayer Network
um so I've been seeing a lot of uh
Trends here and I think for for us we
are uh quite prepared for the trends
here and we have different tools like
including like Skylink we also have the
data Highway uh actually can on board
different autoi assets uh with the uh
Oracle uh from offing to onch um so
yeah yeah I think from what what we see
is uh yeah definitely permissionless
environments are are getting more
traction um I think we see defi catering
towards trafi I think unisa before is a
great example of that we're now building
a hooks Library so so soon you'll be
able to use open Zeppelin hooks uh for
for V4 to have let's say a kyc check
before someone does a trade um and I
think we also see you know I think uh
kedo has Paladin we see chain link with
their privacy manager that they just
recently launched which in is part of
their Swift integration so I think we're
we're seeing you know um projects cater
to stratify B on these permission list
Network so obviously yeah maybe
governments will need to have uh more
more control and they won't go there um
but I think we're definitely very
bullish on permiss permissionless
networks I think we're seeing more uh
also people like modifying the rollup
Stacks I think unit chain is an example
of that um so you know eventually you
could imagine trfi going there I think
for now they're very focused on like
more simple use cases that's what we're
seeing at least you know launching
stable coins rwas so it's it's not you
know defi is still like innovating and
at the Forefront but you know we're more
and more catering towards uh trfi and I
guess yeah eventually I think bringing
more people that are in permission
networks over to permission list yeah
very cool so it sounds like both will
exist side by side and there's already
tools that being built to connect uh
connect them both so maybe let's unpack
that one layer deeper right it's like an
onion we try to get deeper and deeper
each time let's really focus on privacy
which is sort of what what the core
topic that was spiled out I always find
that privacy has a bit of this um irony
or contradiction on one hand of course
you want your transactions to be private
right especially when it comes towards
real world applications you don't want
the whole world to know how much you
have what you're doing and so there's
already a bunch of privacy Solutions but
on the other hand you know when it's
talk about getting to the real world the
government doesn't really want it to be
private right it wants it to be private
until let's say something bad happens
then it sort of wants you to make it
unprivate so that they can see who it is
so I would love to hear kind of from a
product from a technology standpoint
because each of you are solving this in
very different ways very different value
propositions how do you think about this
privacy issue especially in sort of a
real world context where you want to be
private on one hand but then someone
might knock on your door and say oops
you know can you not make it private
let's make it public to me
so uh I can start first uh so from you
know uh for such a long time I've been
talking to lot of the banks uh and a lot
of Institutions about the ZK solution
uh when I work at you know
polyedra and I think you know for plume
it's going to be the same but it's going
to be more flexible so how we fixing
this like uh privacy preserving issue
that we're facing for most of the you
know institutional Partners or you know
required by Mas hkma or other Banks uh
in the in the world is actually using
the zero knowledge proof uh technology I
think it's uh it's actually the future
because it can be uh it can be
selectively private preserving so it can
uh incurve the message that you don't
want to get revealed to the public but
you can also selectively you know open
the key for the key um I say manager of
the message for example like Mas if they
want to check on the message every time
on the transactions we can pass them the
uh encryption key to them so they have
the key they can open the message they
can check out what's happening there but
also for the banks itself they can also
check on the you know uh transactions uh
to most of the res so sorry let me just
interrupt you right there who gets to
decide who gets the key is it plume or
is it the project I would say the
project cuz you know it's a we're
permissionless uh chain and we provide
the tools for everyone so we don't
interfere you know their development but
they get to choose like I want uh like
they get they get to choose the owners
of the keys when they they're doing this
like privacy preserving selection uh and
also on the other other side for plume
cuz we're permissionless right but we
definitely don't want like dirty money
to come in and we don't want but at the
on the other hand we don't want people
to do like kyc all the time and you know
like for the Privacy issue a part of
that we actually build this like uh
money laundry firewall uh it's a chain
level firewall so for everyone for every
every single cryptocurrency come into
plume we make sure that it match with
the AML standard uh globally and also we
uh have the we have a pair with the
Privacy preserving key uh that can be
selectively disclosed to the key
Partners in the in our blockchain
ecosystem
yeah no I totally agree with the ZK part
I think that's definitely uh part of the
like most the most um Advanced and the
thing that comes close to what uh the
institutions want to see and I'm a big
fan by the way of what you guys are
building in that space um we are tany we
can cover a large number of use cases
right and um most of them are more um D
gen use cases def use cases but of
course we have also the uh the
institutions as well U I'm also from
Brazil and many many panelists and
speakers here today are from Brazil and
we are seeing a lot as you guys already
know in the institutional space in
Brazil and that's a very very recuring
Demand right so uh when it comes to tany
what we are looking for is pretty much
like incorporating The Cutting Edge ZK
solutions to to pretty much solve
exactly what you're explaining right now
um and yeah could you agree
more yeah I I think what at least we're
seeing is that I mean there's a lot of
people that um yeah obviously there's
the cipher pun values of privacy and um
you know there's a fine line with that
with governments wanting to know what's
going on and you know people have to
maybe pay their taxes or or whatever um
sorry maybe yeah maybe uh but yeah I
think there's there's a tension there
right between privacy compliance um and
yeah I mean I I I I think that uh
there's there's it's going to depend on
like where where people are uh you know
based uh you know if if the protocols uh
entity is in the US right they're going
to have pressure and a tendency towards
one side if they're outside that might
change so yeah I think we're we're
seeing a bit of everything um there's
still people trying to push for full
privacy you know full full Cipher Punk
values and I I think you know that might
stand in some places and uh yeah yeah I
I I think we're we're we're trying to at
least add to the library uh right now
like the you know simple things simple
extensions to the ear 20 that will make
it easier for institutions to to deploy
and be a little bit more make make it a
little bit more compliant and easier to
to stay complied but yeah I think
there's still like attention there and
the full privacy rollups like Aztec are
still not going to you know still not
launching anytime soon so I think yeah
we'll see what happens when when they
they go live and you can actually have
like you know full full privacy but yeah
um yeah yeah I think it's fascinating to
see how this uh evolves especially as as
we start to get to scale okay so we
checked off the Privacy box let's talk
about the
interoperability segment and and once
again this is any another one of these
paradoxes or oxymorons right you have
chains that are incentivizing
encouraging folks to build on my chain
right I give you grants I give you
support all of that and at the same so
so the idea of doing that is to get
people to build on your chain but on the
same at the same time there are so many
other chains out there that you need to
sort of be inter operable with and we
all know right startups developers there
just finite resources finite time so
really curious to hear how you guys as
Leaders of your respective
infrastructure companies are thinking
about this right how do you it's it's
like on one hand you want people to come
in to build in your your your backyard
but at the same time you want to make
sure that they keep looking out at other
people's backyards and maintain sort of
that relevance which the grass might
always look green on the other side so
yeah I'm curious about how y'all think
about this whole idea of you know really
creating captive apps while figuring out
interoperability yeah I can kick it off
so uh interoperability is definitely one
of the key u aspects for tany right so
and just a step back uh talk a little
bit more about our solution teex teack
in general so we tackle interoperability
uh several ways and also like we are
only viable because of interoperability
right so so for start um teny as I said
the purpose of of of our uh network is
NCH order networks right um and we do
that uh by with a partn partnership
recently announced with
symbiotic uh and uh and when I say
networks maybe you guys are are more
familiar to the concept AVS so AVS uh
was a a term created by Iger and
symbiotic uses Network so just to make a
parallel here uh so uh the the
operational system for restak that we
use in our in our solution is powered by
by symbiotic and that's first
interoperability layer uh okay once we
have the the um the operational system
we have to attract liquidity right and
another uh another protocol that we
interoperate with is Renzo because these
are the guys who are routing the
liquidity through the the operational
system in order to secure the chains
that not only tensy chain but also the
chains that tensi is putting together
and launching right um and that's in our
text but then of course if you're going
to launch many many app chains many uh
networks um would be amazing like if if
we could make these guys interpretate
right so for doing that we are
integrating now with ag polygon Ag and
CYO Network these are two of the uh
leaders in this uh in this U shared
shared liquidity uh
aspect sorry so that's another aspect of
interoperability uh and last but not
least least uh when you deploy your
network with teni we also have in our
base layer um um Native interoperability
layer on which you can Bridge assets you
can exchange messages uh and that's all
like without necessarily using any
Bridge so we just use our text stack and
our kind of layer zero so to say uh and
we provide this interoperability out of
of the box as well and of course we are
integrated with the main uh Bridges and
gmps in the market such as axler
wormhole
um you know several of them so I think
definitely as I was saying in the
beginning right so that's definitely one
of the the directions that we we are
going so multi-chain multi whatever AVS
multi Network space um and of course the
interoperability is a key part so we
definitely need to solve that not only
uh for the developer uh not right so
improving the developer experience but
also uh for the user we it's not trival
to to reach assets so that's that's uh
the main challenge I would say in that
in that
sense yeah I will be the next uh so from
uh from you know the train level I will
say evm compatibility is the first thing
for interrup uh for interrup ability
because you know there are uh I would
say there are a lot of D5 protocols
they're pivoting to you know rw5 RW plus
D5 protocol
uh into our space and to be the evm
compatible chain makes it easier for the
protocols uh to move or to transfer from
or to be multi-chain basically uh on
plume and so that's going to be the
first thing and the second thing will be
the interr interrup ability between the
offchain uh data and the onchain data
because we are the r Focus chain and we
have a lot of um surprisingly we have a
lot of traditional build or projects
that actually want to deploy on plume so
like they're asking for help because
they don't understand blockchain but
what they can do here is using our tools
like we have the data uh highway to
provide the Oracle solution and we
partner with other third party uh
protocol uh Oracle provider for example
like chain link to help them to get on
board but with all of those like
traditional Builders or traditional
projects uh projects Brands IPS they can
actually on board on plume with data
Highway easily because we have the uh
interoperability from you know to to
provide for them from offchain to
onchain and the third thing is uh the
thing that we're building on chain the
interruptable the interoperable uh arway
yields so which we can take in the
assets from other chains like the you
know for example like uh ethereum of
course and uh some other like uh big
layer one and layer twos we can take the
assets from there chain and then deploy
into our arway saking pool so their
users stay their users stay on their
chains but at the same time they can get
the RW yields passed back from plume to
their chains so that's also uh kind of
like the yield liquidity pool that we're
building for other chains too
yeah yeah I think interrupt I mean if
you're going to talk or you've been on
like crypto Twitter over the past few
weeks you've seen it I think the a big
topic um please be loud about it whether
that's complaining or building towards
it like I think for the sake of etherium
you know we've skilled we it's amazing
we have all this block space but it's
it's quite messy if you've used a de or
even just a wallet it's it's not a good
user experience and I think as we merge
with trfi we want to make sure that we
we are the better user experience so I
mean yeah we have been uh working on a
standard we actually tried to introduce
uh Crush chain into a open Zeppelin
contracts Library um more than a year
ago we had to deprecate it it was very
hard to keep up with all the rollups um
we've actually just published a new
standard um 7786 if you want to take a
look at it uh I know there's a lot of
other standards out there we're trying
to gather uh there are a lot of people
meeting this week and hopefully we can
you know agree to a Way Forward uh when
it comes to evm to evm um yeah messaging
obviously there's a lot of like
interrupt providers like chain link
Wormhole axel layer zero and some others
but I think it's important that we get
to a standard and I think in the
previous panel someone mentioned that
like yeah the the tooling and the user
experience is not great I think yeah we
it's because we have all these different
providers and so um yeah I think it it
it's definitely a big Focus for us uh
you'll be able to yeah see see the
proposal we made eventually that this
will come into the library uh obviously
we're trying to make it so that you know
it's a standard it's vendor agnostic and
an open Zeppelin hopefully can act as
that you know neutral place that that uh
people can go to but at the same time
obviously you know there's interesting
uh things that chain link provides uh
with maybe uh Swift integration right so
we've tried to make it as um let's say
modular as possible so that you can use
if you want to still use Axel you still
want to use chain link or any other
Bridge provider you can but really make
it easy to just have
interrup in in yeah in in uum and I
think yeah it's big big problem we want
to solve especially as new people come
in because you you end up losing people
to other other ecosystems so yeah and
actually we've we also worked hard to to
um make it not only evm to evm uh
focused right so uh we're we're we've
aligned it to the chain agnostics uh
Improvement proposals which basically
tried to look at non-ms as well and as
we've actually started expanding open
zein contracts outside of solidity we've
tried to align our our interrupt
standard with that so that should also
help I guess with with trfi and maybe
some permission chains that are not evm
uh but yeah I think that's big big Focus
uh yeah very cool so we're almost at
time so maybe in the last one minute or
two minutes what I would love is for
each of the panelists to share how you
can support the builders the developers
the founders in this room um to really
whether it's on permission or
permissionless chains I know you guys
have already shared a bit but maybe just
in 30 seconds to one minute share you
know how each of your infrastructure
your your blockchains can really support
the audience
here I can start yeah so the our Holy
Grail is pretty much that we don't need
to provide any support right because it
should be as smooth as possible in a way
that uh no support is needed actually
all the framework that I described uh is
codeless right so when you deploy your
network with T it's pretty much like
installing a software in your computer
so you just go next next next you give
give some parameters and that's it right
so at the end of the process which take
about 10 minutes you deploy your own
chain and this chain has already
connectivity to wallets block explorers
indexers rpcn points all of that all the
interoperability that we just described
um and then but but you leverage uh rest
assets and like rest rest rest liquidity
as the the means of security for a chain
right so um we have we are very very
focused in our documentation so uh the
idea is that if this very simple process
that we establish is not enough then you
have a very robust documentation because
um you know if any of you guys here is
working in a in a web tree protocol uh
as much we talk a lot about
interoperability we talk a lot about how
uh things should be um you know
permissioned and everything but the very
first step of integrating is always
let's create a telegram group right so
and that's uh our our idea is pretty
much to you know that this telegram
group is not necessary anymore so that's
uh how we see that but of course like we
are super happy to connect to the
community always that's just like a a a
mantra we have in the product side um
any yeah we have different ways to to to
interact we are always open to to chat
and and telegram uh Discord whatever is
the method WhatsApp it's very used in
Brazil signal you guys choose it uh and
yeah happy to connect if any anyone want
to chat before after
this yeah I mean uh something we've
actually just made public there's a new
repo uh if you go to GitHub called open
Zeppelin Community contracts uh so you
know we're actually starting to make it
easier for people to contribute to open
zein contracts obviously the vanilla
repo is you know where it it gets
heavily audited and you know that's
production ready code but uh obviously
we want to make it easier for people to
start building um extensions to the
library that maybe cater more towards
trfi so you know you can contribute
there if you're a developer or see
what's what's going on uh and if not
yeah we also have you know a booth we
have a lot of our team here uh at Devcon
so you know feel free to come up to us
uh we're really trying to focus on
interop we're also doing some stuff
around ERC 4337 and adding that to the
library but if you have some cool ideas
around like compliance and privacy we're
always happy to hear we're trying to
we're yeah we I don't think we have a
clear path forward to how what we add to
the library um so yeah we're still in a
I guess a research phase there but um
yeah if you have any ideas there I we'd
love to talk to
you uh yep for Plum we have uh different
tools first of all it's going to be our
tokenization engine for all of the
traditional or the crypto users to
tokenize their assets easily on PL by
clicking a few buttons and you're going
to tokenize the assets it's very easy
and also we have the modular services
that pair with the requirements of each
uh protocols for example some of them
might need you know support from the
compliance side from the kyc side from
the legal side we all have uh the
supports from there for them and we also
have uh the grant program so we're
giving our Plum uh grants uh and if
you're the art fter come talk to me and
we have over 180 uh ecosystem project
building on plume already and they're
live on taset uh and we're going to
launch them in that very soon it's going
to be in a month and also for the user
growth uh because I was the CMO at
polyhedra I did the largest campaign at
okx cryptopedia campaign it was uh with
over 100 million participations so you
can trust me on user growth campaign and
I'm going to lead the mnet campaign uh
for plume and we're going to have a lot
of interesting showcases and um you know
like use cases uh for the art five
scenarios so yeah come talk to me if you
want to be on plume okay forgot to
mention we have grants too
so free money so grab these guys all
right please join me with a warm Round
of Applause to thank our panelist today
and thank you so much for your attention
back to you
Bruno well we are almost wrapping up
here but still have a Q&A session uh I'm
going to invite Camila Roha that going
to lead the this last panel but Camilo
is going to also introduce herself and
talk a little bit about uh what she's
working on uh but Camila feel free and
then I'm going to invite the the
moderators and the panelists to stay
here so if the the public has any
questions we're happy to take
thank you Bruno for the opportunity and
everybody for being around what a
journey right so far for those of you
who don't know me just yet my name is
Cam I am the founder and president of
wait a
second
she how are you doing it so far
let me give it to the master because
maybe it only replies to
Bruno while he tries his best my name is
CA I am the founder and president of
plexus Institute an Institute focused in
democratizing access to the benefits of
emerging technology I'm here to do a
very quick intro on something we would
love to collaborate on with you guys and
also make um an invitation
so tomorrow 6:00 p.m. we're going to be
in the blue meeting room this is an open
space you just if you're here in
presence you're going to see it there's
no way around it and we are going to be
discussing this open call to collab this
open call to collab yes we're almost
there just when we need
it on a very interesting project plexus
Institute signed a partnership agreement
with a city hall the city hall has one
app it's a web two app that has around
1.5 million already people already on
boarded and they're using this app to
have access to public services and to
public goods and they inquired us how do
we take the next step how do we bring
more benefits to the population based on
emerging technology what is the role
that blockchain blockchain
opsource technology could bring to us
upon this question what we reped to them
that the best thing that this type of
Technology could bring is the community
so what did we agree on and we can move
to the next
step doing a partnership where we could
invite the community to tip on what type
of Technology should be built what type
of use cases should be built and they
have a very particular interest in this
spect which is community
currencies Brazil has over
170 Community Banks and Community
currencies that don't operate under the
same rules as the traditional Banks but
rather through legislation that is done
on a community and Municipal level so
it's an opportunity to experiment with
other ways of lending money of paying
social benefits and rewarding the
population on the next slide where are
we right right now so we conducted the
first assessment on what this technology
or the evolution of this web 2 to web 3
more connected to the individuals with
popular governance could look like and
now we are on phase two we landed here
with an open Q&A if you would like to
scan this qer code we are asking you for
feedback what should a wallet provide
for in the best ethos of our
community how should the individuals
privacy be protected what are the best
governing rules of a community currency
what is the backing that is needed and
what type of Economics should this
initiative be focused and aimed at after
we are done analyzing these responses
there are going to become a public
collaborative study the municipality has
agreed to host a popup City and do a
regulatory sandbox so we can all explore
with this opportunity feeling safe in a
very nice environment so if this topic
is of interest to you please meet me and
other fellow people 6 p.m. at the blue
meeting room without further Ado let's
continue to our Q&A session I would like
to invite the moderators to take place
uh here again with
me maybe give them a round of applause
just so they you know feel excited of
coming back here
please moderators take your
seats yes we have the first Courageous
one this woman is actually from the
municipality that I we signed a
partnership agreement with yes let's
have Bruno back we still have one chair
who's the missing
moderator
yes amazing so let's start with you the
audience does anybody have an
interesting question to pose to this
amazing group of
people come on it's been almost two
hours if you are here you really like
us can I start with
her well my question is actually on the
board behind you um it's a philosophical
question just given that we're quite a
few years on from the Panama papers and
the end of um Swiss banking secrecy and
so I'm curious what your thoughts on are
on the future of privacy in banking
especially given how the entire push of
blockchain has been about
transparency thank
you yeah yeah I will say for from the
banking level because I'm not a banker
but you know from my experience talking
to all of the banks I think permission
blockchain or permission messaging layer
is the must cuz you have to keep
uh you know like the information safe
within the uh banking system but how it
can break the boundary like between the
permission blockchain and the uh public
blockchain for example plume
permissionless blockchain how we can
pass the yields or you know accept the
assets from them is that basically the
interoperability tool so I would say you
know the Privacy should be strict and
that's how uh all of the banks can
protect users privacy and also can match
with you know the requirements of uh SEC
uh Mas uh hkma but I think on top of
that or you know like to pair with that
we have a lot of Solutions in the
blockchain space like for example like
Bridge you know messaging layer re layer
Network we have a lot of solutions that
can actually bring the good assets to
the blockchain or you know actually get
the information uh out from the
blockchain uh and also I think like
again like ZK proof can be a very good
solution because it can be uh
selectively uh disclosed uh for on any
kind of information that you want to you
know select and provide for the Mas or
any kind of regulators
yeah so happy to add on so I I think
even before we go into the technology
just very much just from a regulatory
perspective or even just just from a
very general perspective I think the the
view is that some information has to be
kept private and confidential so for
example in a lot of countries you have
like banking secrecy act that looks at
you know the the preserving the the
confidentiality of this information and
even before that just um gdpr for
example uh around privacy uh um of
personal identifiable information so I
think from that perspective privacy is
Paramount there is no you can't even
debate that
yeah so so yeah just just from that
perspective I think um you know you you
you can't have any that there just
really isn't anywh else around privacy
um having said that so from a technology
perspective there are really different
means of dealing with this need for
privacy um especially when it comes to
personally identifiable information uh
the general approach is don't even think
about storing it on blockchain because
like what heart was mentioning earlier
the whole idea around store now decrypt
later you could have it encrypted today
you have no idea what would happen to it
5 years 10 years from now so um the
general approach is pii we wouldn't even
think about storing on blockchain um the
next level is really what sort of
information do we need private to keep
private or confidential again some of
these things was mentioned earlier in
terms of like maybe certain information
are Market sensitive if they are Market
sensitive they might be sensitive for a
couple of years so from that perspective
do you you you probably need to keep it
secure for that number of years while on
the other hand pii they are pretty much
confidential forever which is why you
wouldn't want to S them on blockchains
yeah perfect no just to complement a a
small detail I think uh when you have
like a regulator a central bank
regulatory Authority or any kind of
financial regulator uh sometimes there
are uh issues that are Beyond uh its
mandate so as we you mentioned so we
have gdpr Bank privacy act so a lot of
those are are legal Frameworks so
they're like regulatory Frameworks so
even the financial regulator cannot move
them so it has to build and solve for
these problems or for these Frameworks
that are already there as
well my uh Adon uh would be that I think
like the future is complex and I think
it will be Platforms in different levels
of privacy so I think there will be
applications from different levels but
yeah I think like in general terms like
the solutions that that we will contract
for banks uh or for similar things in
the future in general there will be
privacy
yeah awesome so we also have a second
question on the screen but I also wanted
to give the opportunity for the people
who are in here anyone
else it's a quick question uh Wiki would
you ever consider you know moving the
the GP Morgan chain as a rollup on
optimism and joining the super chain or
any other like rollup sack have you have
you gotten
offers I it will be back to what I
mentioned earlier you know the the
question that we always have is from a
governance perspective are we able to
rely on the underlying technology itself
um so I I mean we are definitely looking
at row UPS because we see there's a lot
of usefulness uh partly from just a
scalability perspective as well uh but
of course when you think about l2s
rolling up to l1's then there's always a
question of the governance structure of
the L1 itself so um I mean you you
mentioned one of the networks but if we
could be thinking about any other of the
public blockchains we still have the
same governance questions that we had so
um actually I just had this discussion
with like couple of tech folks uh I
think last week or the week before so
you know if we are not able to rely on
the governance of deploying directly on
L1 um the same would you apply we
wouldn't be able to rely on you know
rolling up to that particular L1 itself
so that that's just a high level view
around what we are able to and what we
are not able to based on like current
regulatory or current um interpretation
of regulations and the governance of
these public uh
blockchains so maybe to the second
question that we have on the panel
what's the biggest potential risk of
cbdc for institutional Banks how how
would using a cbdc and blockchainbased
platform change the transaction fees the
traditional transaction fees for
banks okay I I will start with that so
um broadly I would say that we generally
view uh cbdcs and Commercial Bank money
as complimentary uh ABI over there he
can probably share a lot more From
partal perspective but I I'll just share
from my own perspective of having seen
it from both sides so on the Central
Bank side I started working on multic
cbdc projects um very quickly we realize
that we wouldn't from a policy
perspective central banks doesn't want
to widen assets so if they're not
widening assets they always need
Commercial Bank to act as an
intermediary from say a k kyc AML
controls perspective and because of that
eventually The Ledger become a two-tier
Ledger you have cbdcs you have
Commercial Bank money now if you look
from the other perspective which is from
Bottoms Up partal perspective we started
with a commercial bank money essentially
um like US dollar that are true um JP
Morgan as a settlement bank but again
very soon you'll realize that from that
perspective um you know they they're
just you always end up with the need for
multiple settlement Banks so example is
let's say for example Sing dollar you
have DBS as a settlement bank for Sing
dollars but what if one of those client
is not using DBS bank but using another
of the local banks like U for example so
then the question is if you have multi
settlement Banks how do you any enable
settlement across the settlement Banks
uh cbdcs again become a very natural
solution to that so we have seen it from
both sides the eventure uh um Landing
point is really a two-tier kind of
architecture on a common blockchain
itself where you have both cbdcs and
Commercial Bank money uh one of the
biggest blockchain project out there by
central banks today Project Agora I
think that's like uh seven central banks
and I think over 40 financial
institutions this is actually the
specific use case that they are
exploring uh having both cbdcs and
Commercial Bank money on a common
platform and how we are able to use that
to improve crossb payments so broadly
speaking uh I would say that they are
complimentary we don't see a lot of
competitive elements to it we don't
think that we think that you definitely
make payments a lot more seamless but I
don't think you'll significantly disrupt
uh how payments is being done
today yeah just to complement that when
you talk about cbdcs there are like
different versions of cbdc initiatives
and there are different Dimensions as
well so weq is mentioning the
international Dimension so crossb cbdc
uh rails right multi cbdc Arrangements
but also there are countries uh such as
the ones we mentioned in Brazil that are
deploying a infrastructure blockchain
based infrastructure that's thinking
actually Beyond payments because a lot
of those countries already have payment
rails instant payment rails already have
data with open finance and open banking
so they are like think what would be
like the next chap so like creating an
an an infrastructure an ecosystem that
can leverage emerging Technologies such
as blockchain and label broad terization
of economy so we're talking H in
specific situations specific CC
initiatives more about rwa doation of
Securities of financial assets of the
capital markets uh not only like the
payment side of course the payment lag
being like a deposit oriz deposit or
cbdc for the wholesale side is very
important for the DVP but uh the asset
part I think uh it's the one that's
being pushed and it's the actual goal in
specific CBC initiatives mostly on the
domestic level
unfortunately we are running out of time
so I would kindly ask no maybe the two
of you to say a few last words prior to
us giving the word back to Bruno oh oh
sure so uh a little bit comments on that
so I think uh cbdc is a a great way for
uh cross crossb payment and also on top
of that uh we're talking to you know
some of the project like from uh project
sample they are actually figuring out
how how they can pass the yields back to
the cbdc holders so so I think you know
like partnering with maybe some
blockchain Partners can make it more
flexible uh you know globally yeah just
a little bit comments on that yeah yeah
my fin my final comments are related to
financial inclusion so we still have 1.4
billion people that are financially
excluded and as if you look at the last
10 years technology was a main driver
that helped them help a lot of people
not this 1.5 but not 1.4 but other
people to be financially included so I
truly believe that this this new
technology are unlocking uh new
possibilities to financially include
people uh either cbdcs uh uh paks uh in
Brazil or other other ones so I think
it's good and on the other ones once
more the invitation to join us tomorrow
6 PM for talking about the community
currency that brings the possibility
that builds upon what you think it
should be the best Avenue to bring goods
for a population that it's awesome Bruno
now handing back to you uh in the name
of everybody I think we thank you for
the opportunity to be here please your
final words oh perfect now just I want
to take everyone for spending the last
two hours after five panels like of an
intense debate with us and we are pretty
open to uh have like some discussions
after the panel and I think I had an
awesome time also want to to thank all
the panelists uh many of them that flew
uh to to Bangkok to be here today and
presenting to you so and thank you for
the foundation and Dev con team Skyler
uh Nathan and all all the gang uh for
yeah having letting us have some fun for
with you guys for the the best two hours
was was incredible thank you so much you
guys have a nice one and I hope you
enjoy
[Applause]
Devcon you guys want to take
picture you guys want to take a picture
[Music]
you
that
[Music]
m
any
[Music]
you you
going I
[Music]
play
oh
[Music]
was the
everyone else
[Music]
what
e
[Music]
oh for
oh
[Music]
a
for
[Music]
a
for
[Music]
oh
for
[Music]
that
e
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
she
n
[Music]
back
o
[Music]
for
all
[Music]
m
oh
[Music]
h
oh
[Music]
is
w m
[Music]
for
is
[Music]
m
is
[Music]
is e
for for
[Music]
is
oh
[Music]
for
oh
[Music]
e
oh
[Music]
h
a
[Music]
m
oh
[Music]
for e
thank you
[Music]
oh the
e e
[Music]
oh
yes another microphone for another
speaker
[Music]
can you give him the
mic hi
everyone thank you very much for joining
this Workshop today my name is Marina
and I'm coming from the European crypto
initiative which is an advocacy group
based in Brussels in Europe uh we are
going to talk today about regulation and
we have first a panel um we have a very
special guest uh we're going to
introduce later uh but today we are also
going to do a workshop after that uh and
basically the first part is going to be
a panel after the panel we're going to
sit in groups this is why we have tables
here and we are going to discuss
different topics uh some can be dii me
staking wallets privacy whatever you're
interested in so you're going to join
each group and uh each table and we're
going to have moderators helping you
with the discussion so this is the plan
for today I wanted to give uh two
minutes to speak also to Florian but I
think after that after a short intro
we're going to go quite straight into
the panel we're very eager to hear what
regulators have to say about crypto
regulation thank you Marina I'm just as
excited as you about this workshop and
the panel and uh welcome everybody
excited you're here thank you very much
thank
you
[Music]
so thank
you I would like us to join all together
our speaker um we are very privileged to
have I don't know if you can change the
slides as well thank you very much so
we're very privileged to have a
regulator here with us coming at Devcon
for the first time so I hope you like
the conference uh from the Japanese FSA
uh and it's isida ruk uh very very much
thank you for joining us and uh I think
it's an
amazing it's an amazing uh um in way
speaker as well just because of all your
experience uh you have in crypto uh you
had a lot of um yeah a little bit
unusual story uh about uh about how you
came into crypto and how you started
learning about it as well but um I
wanted to maybe start with this uh
apparently you have studied uh computer
science as well you were very interested
in crypto you have even been um running
notes Etc so maybe give us a little bit
of introduction on this side as well
sure so thank you Marina and then good
afternoon everyone so thank you for
having Regulators like me for this U
developers conference obviously I'm a
minority among all of you but uh and so
Japan FSA is a regulator like USS or
Bank of Thailand or ukfc and then we
regulate basically everything like Banks
uh insurance company as well as crypto
service providers and then what I am
doing is um uh to encourage and
Innovation uh with emerging technology
such as blockchain and AI so as a chief
inch officer um one of our important
mission is to bring a international
expert like you to come into Japanese
Market because we are a more competition
among local players and we want to make
Japan as a one of the as a Global Hub of
crypto and the blockchain industry then
personally I spent uh two years as a
blockchain researcher at a georgtown
university in Washington DC so I started
my career as a Regulators back in 2010
and then since then I have been
doing not boring but you know
traditional Financial regulator job but
suddenly my boss asked me to do
something about blockchain and I had no
idea at that time what what is
blockchain and why why they have to go
there but
somehow I decided to go there and it was
fascinating because I had a lot of
opportunities to discuss Bitcoin
developers eum developers who have
totally different mindset from
Regulators so you know basically they
it's a it's like you know six or seven
years ago basically you know they hate
government they hate Regulators in many
cases so when I say you know I'm from
regulator so I don't talk to you anyway
so this kind of things it's a very kind
of unique opportunities for me to Lear
um how we can communicate with um
engineers and other business people
coming from you know crypto industry
then you know I spent a lot of time to
learn about internet governance and the
blockchain governance and then we
realize you know we should develop kind
of mutual understanding between
regulators and the developers and the
business Community to make a blockchain
really
uh to have a really you know to make our
society better is this and Innovative
technology I'm happy to talk and
anything today thank you very much thank
you so much this is a very fascinating
story uh my NE next question would go
more into how Japan is regulating crypto
assets you were um one of the first to
actually react to crypto to the crypto
industry to exchanges because you had
this specific event that happened with M
go in 2014 over already so uh after that
you have also been pretty I would say
famous for um some kind of protecting
your users from other exchanges collaps
that happened recently as well so um
what is the whole story of the Japanese
FSA and how the regulation came into
place from the beginning until now maybe
I think it's a little bit more focused
on exchanges but that's the interesting
thing for us
so um 10 years 10 years ago um more than
80% of Bitcoin transactions was taking
place in an exchange in Tokyo named the
mount go which is run by a french guy
and then Regulators didn't know that at
that time but uh suddenly uh 500 million
us do equivalent Bitcoin was disappeared
and they not only Japanese investor but
also International investors lost their
Bitcoin and still you know court process
is ongoing to get their fund back so we
realize that it's a huge industry and
they probably growing very much in the
future so we decided to make a
regulation for crypto asset service
providers so um that's why Japan is one
of the very first country to implement
crypto regulation back in
2017 so basically we require crypto
exchange and to do kind of kyc or some
you know uh customer protection
requirement then even after that we had
another series of incident if you may
know coin Che is one of the large
largest Japanese exchange and again
nearly 500 million US dollars of name
name was hacked and then even after we
have a regulation so we are kind of
freaked out so we have to Titan
regulation that's why we introduced
socaled a code wallet requirement it's a
requirement asking exchange to reserve
more than 90% of customer asset into
offline environment so
that's that's something you know
industry didn't like at all because you
know they need a liquidity management so
it doesn't make sense from business
perspective to put most of their crypto
asset into Cod wallet but uh actually
that regulation worked when FTX uh
incident happened because um FTX Japan
segregated their customers asset into
within Japan that's why unlike many
other countes investor Japanese investor
got their fund back much earlier than
other countries investors so that's
that's something uh we made it but uh I
don't think you
know I believe we have to change update
our regulation according to the
development of technology so these days
we have a you know
MPC wet or some other technologies that
makes custody safe even though in hot W
environment so it's technology is
changing that's why I'm here to learn
what's going on this industry and then
we try to keep update to develop a
policy that makes sense both industry
and the ordinary people and The
Regulators that's a very interesting
story because from the European side we
have started in 2017 but we
still have not yet you know a regulation
that is applicable at this moment so it
took us quite a long time and you had
regulated exchanges already in 2017 so
that was uh much more efficient I would
say a governance from from a regulatory
point of view um I think the consumer
protection is really something that you
achieved and that was really efficient
from you know the whole story that
happened with exchanges and the very
interesting thing also the approach Cold
Storage um and basically in way
segregation of funds and being really
careful with what and where the funds of
the of the customers are um right now
you're thinking about maybe updating
like you mentioned and learning more
about the Technologies but what do you
think in general is the best approach
for Consumer Protection like what is
really important what is really
efficient to make sure that the
consumers are not losing funds and that
they are safe which is in a way some of
the most important uh goals of of a
regulator so I think what matters is
bance so and in general Innovation
should come from open source Community
like the internet and the Bitcoin and
then if we introduce strong regulation
from day day day one maybe it could cyle
Innovation so now we have a regulated
World such as centralized crypto
exchange and then not very much
regulated world like you know Bitcoin
Network or some defi protocols and then
we have to be careful about you know
what uh we should do to have a balanced
uh growth so from consumer consumer uh
protection perspectives so anyone can
have easy access to centralized exchange
that's why we put a um kind of a tough
regulation on them because you know it's
a onl of ramp and it's ordinary
people will have to change their fat
Curren into crypto that's why exchange
is heavily regulated and then when it
comes to you know Dex lending and
whatever M it's a kind of market for
crypto enthusias so it's like you know
probably they know their risks and they
know what they're doing so it's a kind
of you know place that they should take
their
responsibilities but uh on the other
hand when we think think about you know
anti you know money laundering or
terrorist Finance so this days are North
Korean and haer are kind of attacking
Bridge protocol and then D5 protocol and
then they are throwing tons of crypto
asset so that's that's something you
know we cannot tolerate because you know
customer is okay because you know they
got a compensation but if the
crypto but transferred to North Korea
you know basically we we can do anything
to prevent that so that's consumer
protection in one thing but money
laundering terorist financing and
financial stability it's another
negatory goal so we have to think both
of
them actually Financial stability is an
interesting one because it was followed
and it was important for many regulators
and somehow they usually connected to
the regulation around stable coins as
well so I would assume that as you
mentioned that that's also something
that it's kind of important for you as
well indeed so stable coin is very
promising so that could be a bridge
between try and then Defi and indeed so
many Japanese uh financial institutions
and the Enterprise are looking at uh
stable coin to make something happen so
that's why we have introduced stable
coin regulation June last year and we
are now discussing both local and then
International potential issues of St
stable coin potentially denominated in
JPY so um you right so that could have a
financial stability implications so
basically it's like you know banking uh
deposit but it's good for crossb
transfer and then some you know payment
or some investment so that's has that
much flexibility and then that could be
good for financial stability in a sense
because you know we have more regant and
then um kind of faster payment system
but at the same time we have to think
about where that Reserve asset protected
and where how that internal control and
then governance are put in place for
both issues and intermediaries so that's
and something you know we would like to
have a more engagement with uh industry
players so we have a centralized stable
coin while you know decentralized or
algorithmic stable coin so there are a
varet types of stable coin and the
different governance mechanism so
there's no one side fital solution so we
have to think about each of them
individually since we started with
centralized and decentralized stable
coins I would go to the next question
which is
you know non-centralized entities like
non non-centralized exchanges which are
usually called decentralized exchanges
or any type of D5 projects Dows Etc we
have seen that iosco for example the
international organization of Securities
um agencies has also written a report on
defi they have written some suggestions
to how to regulate defi they were in a
way talking about the risks and how to
limit this those risks what are you
thinking about those you know no very in
a way centralized entities and of course
it's a whole Spectrum you can be you
know in a different I would say level of
of decentralization but it is an
important topic and it seems that it has
been important enough that International
organizations have been talking about it
and even you know writing paper and
doing research on
that um so I was in um
Malaysia po two weeks ago to join I SC
meeting among regulators and then the
topic is Defi and the crypto assets so
um many Regulators including the US and
the marriage and Security Commission are
there to discuss how we could
potentially mitigate the risks that a
defi could bring so
um basically know there
is So Def is very different um by
project so and sometimes you know Defy
is just in name only and then and it's a
kind of marketing world so we can
actually identify someone who are who
have a significant in significant
influence over that arrangement in that
case um you know they could potentially
update their protocol or change
parameter or you know and get some fees
out of that Arrangement so in that case
uh we might have you know we could
potentially identify someone as a
regulated entity and apply you know
similar regulatory requirements that we
are applying for centralized exchange
but uh having said that it is difficult
to identify who is actually playing the
game so probably we know you know
Twitter name on the but we don't know
where they live and what the actual real
name of those um developers so that's
quite difficult but uh still you know
there are some entity like um Foundation
or lab and then some you know Community
or legal entity so that could be a kind
of contact point for us so what what is
kind of encouraging encouraging for us
is you know some D5 Community are
willing to work with us so I'm
co-chairing Financial action task force
crypto set working group so it's about
you know kyc traval R and then some
others and I think I believe you know
some of you don't like mlfy regulation
but uh we invited a lot of D5 players
and they have a good discussion over a
couple of years so um we we're working
closely with industry to come up with
good solution that works both of us for
for the
future I think the industry has been
more and more mindful of the defy in
name only as well and we're trying to
understand internally also what are the
standards what decentralization actually
mean and I think it's also more and more
um in a way possible and important that
we really strive for decentralization
within the industry as well so hopefully
we can I would say also from an industry
perspective give a little bit more as a
kind of a feedback or summary to what
the industry really thinks those
elements are and and how to really
Define that um on the other topic you
mentioned you are part of the um FFF as
well organization so those organizations
I think are trying to kind of find a
global approach to crypto when it comes
different topics how um how do you think
this approach is in a
way playing are we really going to be
able to have a global regulation or at
least regulation that is compatible to
each other and you know certain
standards that would allow the projects
the technology to be Global and to
basically in a way also um approach and
work in different
jurisdictions so um International
Organization like fat I score FSB are
trying to set a kind of minimum standard
uh globally uh for to ensure kind of
Level Playing Fields and then F it's
taking care of ml safety part and then
we have a standard recommendation 15
which is all about you know how ml safty
control should be in place for crypto
service players and
then the problem we are facing is that
there are many count are still not
implementing that recommendation because
it's
to be honest it's a very difficult so
it's you know some country like you know
some small small small countries in
Asian Pacific regions you know they are
strug struggling to have a enough human
resources and then take capabilities to
develop their regulatory framework and
then it's not only about creating
regulation but you know they have to do
enforcement or supervision like every
day but you know it's quite technically
challenging and then
probably they have to use know
blockchain analytics tools and some
others but uh I think they need more
education that's why uh F of is um
focusing on how we can provide a
technical assistance for those uh
struggling with um um implementing
recommendation so we will have a seminar
or and the poent sometimes we will
invite private sector players like you
know exchangers or blockchain analytics
to Providers to share their you know
kind of risk assessment and then to
share how to use their tools for example
so that's a ongoing challenges but we
hopefully we have a good regulation all
over the world many learning on both
sides for sure um so another topic that
has been recently discussed and I would
say mostly in the last few months is the
adoption of crypto and let's say in
general the technology by the
institutional um players and also for
example tokenization that is something
that might be interesting again more for
traditional Finance point of view and
traditional Industries um how do you see
this potential is it are those
activities needing
regulation uh you know to actually be
flourishing
so yeah personally I believe in the
potential of tokenization because you
know
and it's like you
know uh dream but you know if um assets
and liabilities on Bank B seat are all
tokenized it's maybe easy for Regulators
to monitor the transaction because you
know currently we kind of Trust Banks
you know we have a Authority and to ask
Banks to submit us some data to regulate
that and then we will analyze that but
timately it's a trust is needed so
sometimes you know they are they might
give us you know fake data and sometimes
you know frent disclosure incident
happen all over the world
so something it's what is great about
blockchain is a transparency and
auditability so and that makes Not only
industry job but regulator job much
easier and much um efficient in the
future so that could be a future but uh
of course there are potential risks like
you know we can toize a liquid asset
like our real estate but uh to itself is
very liquid potentially but underlying
asset is still IL liquid so we have to
think about misat of liquidity and the
maturity that's one thing and then we
also have to take care of you know smart
contract uh vulnerability for example
it's a kind of different types of
operational risks so I think there are
both opportunities and then risks and
oranization are not taking off that much
from my perspective partly because of
you know we are using a different
blockchain and there is no
interoperability that's why we don't
have a good secondary market and another
thing is
um another thing is that you know we
don't have programmable payment layer so
we can toize Financial instrument like
you know corporate bond real estate but
we need a digital money such as stable
coin Tok deposit or potentially
wholesale cbdc but that they are still
not ready very much so it's I think it's
a long-term project but hopefully we we
have a a lot of tokenization project in
the
future we we mentioned iosa and other
International organizations few times
and we know also that iosco was looking
into any type of initiatives that would
share more about and educate more about
crypto uh mostly thinking about consumer
protection can we do more as an industry
that is a question for us of course can
we share more can we can we educate paid
more anyone that is for example using
our products or the general Community
but I know that um different Financial
authorities they were also thinking
about can we you know do something can
we educate the the community and our
users what uh what is your opinion on
this absolutely so and The Regulators
need education as well because you
know basically you know it's quite
difficult for us to understand the the
technology itself and then it's kind of
regulatory
implication so um we need that kind of
input from industry expert like we about
you know how we can achieve our goals so
we are Tech neutral we are agnostic to
Technologies applied to the financial
system so we don't care it's blockchain
II whatever what matters is to protect
customers and then to prevent Financial
crimes and to ensure Financial
stabilities so we current regulatory
frame Mark has something like you know
disclosure requirement or kyc or travel
but it's a it's just a mean not a goal
so our goal is protecting customers so
if
Technologies could achieve same goals
with slightly different approach
potentially you know we can welcome that
you know instead of traditional kyc we
could potentially use I don't know did
VC or uh privacy enhancing technology
first NPC whatever so but that it's not
something you know Regulators can come
up with so we need a kind of counter
proposal from industry so if you don't
like current regulation you know we are
very welcome and we appreciate and uh
kind of alternative approach that the
industry could come up
with actually we've been discussing a
lot about this uh at the side events
before Devcon and I think there's going
to be a lot of discussion about that
during Devcon as well so it is true it's
also on us to try to propose certain
Solutions and to try to use this
technology in a way that would be at
least for this community it's very
important privacy preserving as well if
there are options for that and of course
this is why we're working on this Tech
so that's very useful thank you and the
last question before we start with the
open question for the audience I hope
you have some uh you are you mentioned
few times that you want to learn from
the community that a dialogue is very
important so so I know that there's been
different organizations that you've been
talking to and also some kind of a
self-regulatory ideas and organizations
as well but um how again how important
how how in a way open um I would say
different
authorities are or or should be in order
to you know do the the kind of um again
to protect the users to the maximum uh
amount possible but also how can we be
useful uh as an industry when we are
talking to Regulators when we are having
this uh great opportunities to discuss
with you uh also in
person sure so so in many case uh
Regulators are not enemy uh to Industry
otherwise you know we are willing to be
a part of um the community to make our
society better with blockchain
Technologies
so um actually we welcome any kind of
dialogue uh with industry so I want to
just say you know please um contact us
and then you know have a discussion and
then that is very important because you
know when we look back look back the
Internet history they used to be a
telecom Regulators regulating Telecom
industry but uh currently no one is
regulating internet itself so they
regulate you know IP or some others but
uh kind of they changed the way of
regulating industry and it works so it's
kind of no miracle that we have that's
why uh now we can use internet so
otherwise you know we are kind of
socially died during the pandemic so we
should appreciate internet innovators
and then regulators and then hopefully
you know blockchain could be something
like the internet in the future and in
order to do so we have we need a more
kind of multistakeholder discussion like
we have today so that yeah just yeah
have a good disc
discussion thank you again very much for
your time
uh and also for your willingness to take
questions from the audience so now is
your time do you have any question on
the topics of Regulation I would say
specifically to of course the Japanese
uh Market in jurisdiction but maybe also
globally since we've discussed the the
regulation coming from International
organizations as
well any questions yeah
hi thank you for your time um what would
be something you would like to see um in
Europe uh in terms of the regulation
um
yeah uh thanks so um they Implement they
will Implement maika and they already
approved some stable coin and some
crypto asset service providers and then
actually we are we have a discussion C
quite frequently because you know we
need a kind of harmonization among
regulation so
um you know I cannot specifically
comment on as countries policy but you
know
basically European regulation and then
our regulation are quite aligned so um
then then what we will do more in the
future is you know Bally blockchain is
uh Global by nature and then some stable
coin issue then Europe could come to
Japanese market and vice versa
and then maybe it's good for industry
players to have a kind of similar
regulation because you know you have to
comply with different types of
Regulation so that's something we can do
more and then now you know after the
election maybe yes Regulators will have
some sort and then many Asian Regulators
are taking different approach but
specifically to Europe you know they are
quite Advanced and then they have a they
will have a global prayer regulated
under the MAA and then they have a good
you know privacy protection regulation
so that's something we can talk more and
we hope our regulation is not kind of
too much on erous to the players like
you thanks Alam for the context I would
like to know about the adoption rate in
Japan because it's super clear how the
regulation but I think that also is
super important to understand how is
adoption in the
countries uh thank you so
I don't remember exact number but uh
there's a millions of um accounts are
already there so basically we have a 30
registered Exchange in Japan and I don't
know why but the Japanese uh retail
investor very much like crypto trading
that's why we had a mon 10 years ago but
still a little investor like crypto so
if you are doing some kind of retail
business I think there are business
opportunities and then when comes to um
large investor like institutional
players basically they are very
conservative and like um some other
countries um Family office hedge fund
but finally they are looking at um
blockchain industry crypto industry so
they are interested in investing in some
crypto asset or using blockchain to to
have a real use case so in case I think
Japanese Market is um growing these
days any other questions
questions okay um since you said
Regulators do actually appreciate the
transparency of uh cryptocurrency what's
your take on the rise of uh zero
knowledge proof technology and the
potential implication of anonymous
transactions yeah it's a good question
it's a kind of
uh W SW so you know for example if we
think about you know interbank
transaction they should be private
otherwise it's a it's very bad from
Financial stability perspective so even
Regulators want some privacy for
specific use cases but uh you know um if
we think about you know something like
uh privacy anding Technologies for
anonymous transaction uh that could be
um very problematic especially if for ML
Shifty perspectives so that's why some
Regulators are taking enforcement action
for the some you know mixers and some
others so it's a we try to be Tech
neutral but you know if speciic protocol
B used by stct maybe we have to take
some actions so um it's use case and
it's intention of the project and then
it's not you know yes and one no
question so we will have a discussion
and then what in this protocol for and
who are actually using that so we will
should we should do an evidencebased
policy making and
regulation any other
questions do you think do you think uh
amlc uh CTF regulations are excessive
when it comes to crypto are these still
stand use
cases question is regulation is
excessive yes
I'm in charge of M regulation so I I
shouldn't say yes but
[Laughter]
uh so rather you know as I mentioned you
know we are now applying you know
conventional way of ml safety to crypto
industry but you
know technology is different so maybe I
don't know about the optimal way of
doing
AML AML safety could be different
so rather than just you know taking
photo or you know sharing passport or
whatever we could do something more like
using NFD or B BCD type solution could
be efficient so that's why we are now
kind of doing some you know poc in with
industry to to kind of you know consider
how we can potentially update our way of
doing so that's I think that's a
longterm goals but what is fascinating
about blockchain is that you know some
supervisory function regulation could be
embeded in smart contract itself so
currently you know Regulators are doing
regulation by human but you know we will
see a kind of machine to machine
transaction in the future very much so
it's probably impossible for Regulators
to do the same thing in 10 years in the
crypto asset industry so we have to
change and then we are welcome
about you know Innovative
solution we had one
more
um hi so um yeah you see more
traditional companies exchanges making
their own layer toos on ethereum so base
for example from coinbase but also in
Japan uh Sony with sonum so in what way
do you look to them to regulate so it's
sort of like a hybrid permission kind of
thing yeah it's a great great question
so many Japanese and Enterprise like
Sony are developing their own blockchain
so um we will see so many layer one lay
Layer Two solution private public same
public and then I'm kind of observing
you know Global layer layer one project
if you may know it's a kind of unified
Ledger and then of bar data at is Big
regulated Banks and the financial
institution can do can toize and some
asset and then cbdc could be issued so
we will see a very different types of
blockchain and then a lot of defi
project and organization project are now
taking place and then what matters for
us is probably um not about technology
itself but more like you know how we can
achieve our goals so we don't care it's
a public or private but what matters is
like no consumer protection as we
discussed so if it's a permissionless
blockchain you know we cannot identify
the kind of bar data and the manager of
that blockchain but it's okay if still
customer is protected in the financial
clme is prevented so it's more like you
know use case and economic implication
rather than underlying technology
itself hi um so I think we've seen over
years how kind of technology has
advanced at a much faster Pace than than
regulation and regulation is now
starting to catch up um but in many
cases the regulation is very much
rules-based and there's a risk that that
regulation soon becomes you know
inadequate for future activities as well
and that's why we're already seeing you
know Regulators looking at different
activities within the ecosystem around
you know staking and defi related
activities everything else how feasible
is it from a regulator's perspective
such as the you know the Japanese FSA or
european authorities in the context of
MAA in drawing up more principle based
regulation as opposed to specific
rule-based legislation which risks you
know becoming outdated and not being
able to cater for you know the broad
spectrum of activities that are that are
being carried out within the
space yeah that's a great question so
you're right so it's probably impossible
to describe everything in our regulation
about what you can do and you cannot do
so uh we try to take you know principle
based or risk based approach for this
space so um what we are asking um to
Industry is to identify risks and to
think about potential risk mitigation
measures and then we will monitor that
and if we think it it's insufficient you
know we will ask you to improve the
operation so that's a basic concept but
having said that you know
we kind of still have a checklist uh for
compliance because you know some
industry players want that kind of
checklist so it's a balance between kind
of prescriptive regulation and the
principle based approach and then in
Japan we have a self regulatory
organization and then they have their
self regulation so there is are more
details and it could be changed easily
compared to law and ordinance so and we
are kind of two-tier approach we law and
then more detailed guideline published
by FSA and then self regulation
developed by an SRO so I hope that works
uh for now but what matters is not only
regulation and then but uh supervisory
judgment so you know if we sometimes you
know it's a kind of judgment by
Regulators what it's good and what is
not so everything is not written in that
regulation itself so that's why we need
a disc discussion with the industry so I
hope that kind of communication could
work hi you talked a little bit about
coordination with the European and
potential future us Securities
Regulators but I also know you know I in
the area I work in which is tax there's
what I see is a lack of coordination
between the Securities regulators and
the tax Regulators there's a regulation
or a guidance Global guidance called
carf that requires any value transfer on
any decentralized network to be
kyc um so even if you were to accept
decentralized identities maybe zero
knowledge proofs on top of those it it
still we have another regime that
requires
identity to be disclosed so it kind of
defeats the purpose can you talk a
little bit about the Dynamics maybe
within the country between the different
regulators and maybe there's others that
I don't know about there's tax there's
Securities maybe there's others who have
a stake in this as
well yeah that's a I think great point
so we are not tax Authority so there's a
different Ministry taking care of tax
and then
so you mentioned about carf uh it's oecd
initiatives and
then what is rcky for us is you know
Financial action task force are also
located in O OCD building in Paris so we
also invite a car representatives to our
meeting and then to share their on
development so what we have in common is
you know the need to trace crypto
transactions so both you know Financial
regulators and the enforcement officers
and tax authorities needed to trace and
that blockchain and the crypto asset so
that's something you know we can share
but we also have slightly different kind
of objectives as Ministry
so yeah it's a kind of a little bit
tricky discussion but as what it at
least needed is to share information and
then to uh work together uh both locally
and internationally and then I think you
know a place like know oecd is a very
good place for the multi-stakeholder
discussion and then we have some
startups to help um people to pay tax uh
appropriately but uh it's still
challenging so I guess you know not many
crypto transaction are you know tressed
enough by tax Authority so that could be
a potential and challenge for the future
so yeah I don't have um very good answer
to your question but what matters is
further
coordination I think there was another
question hello uh so I also had a
further question on coordination so
there's one coordination from the
perspective of uh like uniformity of
some Fair level of regulations uh a lot
of people want that um but you also
mentioned something around some
countries might not have enough
resources to implement that so due to
lack of resources you might find like a
country like Kenya or Nigeria might have
the same regulations as the European
Union but the licensing process takes
close to 18 months for an exchange to
obtain that license what is your
perspective because I'm working on
drafting some regulations in a bunch of
African countries and I wanted to get
your perspective on something called a
FASTT track licensing approach that if
somebody's licensed in
Micah uh all they need is just to pay
the licensing fees cuz that is what the
government cares about and the fact that
they're licensed in a well resourced uh
jurisdiction that has done enough due
diligence on them that is sort of a
standard that just allows them to get
the license within a week so if you're
licensed in Europe and you want to scale
in Africa you just present your European
license pay the licensing fee to the
country and you have a licensing you
have your license within 24
hours yeah so uh regulation and then
licensing and supervision are very very
different so potentially you know any
country could have a similar regulation
to that of Europe or some other
countries but uh you know it's about you
know document but licensing and
supervision is more like you know
practices so you know uh Regulators uh
have to understand their business model
and then the contents of application and
then what is the risks so that kind of
things are kind of not easily achievable
uh by an Imaging countries regulate that
so that's why as I mentioned we try to
give a and assistance to and those
regulators and
then so we of organize you know online
uh webinar for emerging countries
regulator to share uh how you could
potentially Implement travel for example
and how to accept application something
like this so I hope that works uh in the
future but uh you know some country like
you know small African and Asian country
decided to prohibit uh crypto asset
trading but it because it's easy seeming
seemingly but maybe it's not enough just
to ban crypto because you know they have
to make sure that uh cryp trading is um
actually not taking taking place in that
country so
um you know our standard doesn't say you
know every country should have same
regulation but we said kind of minimum
standard and then there is some
discretion by countries to develop you
know additional requirment or you know
to B crypto transactions so
um it's not easy very actually so even
Japan we will we took some time to
develop supervisory practices so um but
you know
they have to start now otherwise you
know some bad act exploiting and such
kind of weak regulations
so
yeah I have no specific answer but you
know yeah we have to work
together so I would say we conclude with
a question um you were very generous
with your time we spoke almost for an
hour so thank you so much for taking all
the questions my pleasure thank you very
much
so this is this concludes the first part
of our Workshop we have more stuff for
you if you want to stay and we very much
welcome you to stay we wanted to go into
different groups and discuss topics so
this is a workshop and it's a workshop
place we really wanted to do it in a
kind of interactive way we will have few
moderators that are helping us within
the discussion and you have the
opportunity to also speak to some of the
most knowledgeable lawyers in the space
um we have here y from uniswap we have
uh also Karen from gnosis and uh we have
Agata from status as well we are
basically going to discuss uh just
internally it's just uh I would say a
workshop and um whatever questions we
have whatever discussions you want to
have internally and we also what we want
to do is basically discuss how to talk
to Regulators that was the title of our
our topic uh on our Workshop because we
see that many times more and more I
would say Tech developers but also
academics are asked to discuss with
Regulators we're also uh seeing that
there's more and more need to basically
discuss certain topics there that could
be very technical like account
obstruction or other other discussions
as well and I think that in this
discussion we can also benefit one from
from each other um so I welcome everyone
to join the uh tables and you just join
the group that you are mostly interested
in so we'll have the group that is
discussing defi one group discussing
privacy and one group that is going to
discuss specifically me inst staking so
if you're interested in one of those
just let us know which one I would say
that this this table should be the defi
group if anyone wants to join uh this
one will be privacy we'll also have
varara helping with this one
and if anyone wants to discuss me
staking it's here and if you want to
discuss any other topic that I have not
mentioned let me know and we're going to
create a new group as well any sorry
stable coins okay perfect yeah I love
this let's make this one stable coins
there any other topic
anyone okay so the discussions are not
going to be recorded is really for our
internal you know topics so I would say
we can be a little bit more chill when
discussing after uh the 30 minutes
discussion we come back and everyone
will just very very shortly report on
this so privacy I think it's privacy is
here defa is here uh this is taking and
MV yeah and this is stable coins okay hi
you recognize me no this event we did an
event on LinkedIn live for
oh my god oh so cool so nice to
heref huh or maybe we should just join
the defi group would that be a thing
yeah okay let's just bring chairs
together
uh no thank you you can just help with
the moderation of the privacy and I
met yeah yeah and she didn't know
anything about oh I
okay aming
okay so yeah you can go there
only million
yeah that's the transaction volume from
those
it's div per person that's like no so
the thing is it's interesting not even
for 95% of that 5 billion is
institutional a lot of African countries
heavily import stuff the and due to
Dollar limitations so the biggest use
that has pushed St adoption is dollar
limitations yeah from local bank African
countries so for me to buy something
from my tanan NE
yes of course it's stable as well you
don't trust I
don't you probably don't you don't want
tan
whatever we don't have a single currency
that we can use within even with our
neighbors you know Kenya
borders they have to trade in the doar
of course every I would also use the
stability stability right
it's a shame so that's why institutions
are using St because of also um the lack
of dollars dollar shortage yeah yeah and
that's of course so we're talking about
Banks right or we talk about um Banks
very big companies we just talking about
fintech fintech okay right uh uh
supplying stable coins to that clients
that clients will be importers exporters
of tea coffee
consum oil andu like people in
Nigeria 300 million oh wow this is
actually great this is a great example
of like crypto because I think it's a
positive change because like trading is
like you know so yeah we can conclude
that the biggest use case for that
volume is institutional yeah inal use
Cas say at the banks so are people
trading with the banks to get usdt or
are they themselves
do they they use Virtual
service okay yeah and they doing deals
with who companies in like outside of
Kenya right no within Kenya within Kenya
they're also for instance if you have if
you have usdt on one end you can just
come in Kenya and set up on it's not
illegal that's good thing so you tell
someone okay deposit Kenya shs in my
account over collateralized and all
no just normal effects R now that is
another interesting thing you mentioned
you see the stable coin Market much
better cheaper than the dollar B so that
is the second so apart from the fact
that there's limitations in terms of how
much dollar a bank can give you $300
million yeah yeah but you can get $300
million no of course yeah but because
you collateralize with but also if a
bank give you $300 million they will
sell it to you at a more expensive rate
a bank will sell you a dollar right now
they will sell you at uh about 134
Kenyan shs per dollar yeah but if you
got it on from an OTC desk if you go to
USD from an desk you get get it as low
as 129 K that's right so that's a five
Shing difference for every dollar yeah
you could do that the bigger the volume
the more money it is yeah so that's
another incentive why a lot of
Institutions are yeah makes sense using
so it's mostly institutional number one
it's mostly for
and exports number two and number three
traditional financial institutions like
banks have not trusted this has created
an opportunity for a new breed of
startups so we're looking at a lot of
tech startups copying in Africa doing a
business doing OTC business doing the
business you're talking about so they
are basically for
ex no there is not they only
[Music]
the only country that has attempted okay
not the only one but the country that
has attempted to regulate the space in
Africa
[Music]
goes
really we want
about guess
spe
don't
okay
want
[Music]
very
heard
I name but I don't I don't know
and
then launched
so the idea is that that you upload
your and
we
open Bally
I can connect you can connect this card
to
yours
lastto noted
exchange are not exch
onlyu butn
B
restaurant
andn po that could have you know
taxation you you know
in Japan you exchange crypto to
something you have to
pay but
may it's easy way
to yeah but it's
very I mean I believe you know you have
some kind of business opportun as well
because there so many
crypto mean Japan is not on our yet
exp yeah just let know where
in Jaan so I'm happy
to for
spe
for
e
e e
up for
spee
spe
number
10 minutes disc
spe for
spe e
for for
is much
yeah I love this
history Rel
I show
so what all
to
variation
fin
right
bike
I
com going
am
distribution you know let's say one
person holding
know kind
ofers so that kind of you
know tokens could have impct on the
valuation of tokens or
this
after
could be a conc
conect
there you business cyp
Cy I will show
you for
for the I'm not
judging going
yeah po you know may have this kind of
discussion I this one I all the China
China
but I don't
but nice very thank you very much I
thank you
very
L for me that I can speak with some
reg the
government come
back
e e
yeah everything
so now is like
thank you very
much
keep one day'll come to Japan I that
good
reason thank you
we need to start Rec
spe
B
AB
working
by
yes hi
everyone I'm inviting the
representatives of different groups to
come here they have the opportunity to
speak at the Devon
Workshop please come it's not that
bad um I think our group will start
first because I know what we discussed
so okay just two minutes two
minutes I'll help you summarize it
you need to come there if you
can so I will start with a very uh like
half a minute introduction our group was
talking about stable coins and we were
very interested to see how other
jurisdictions regulated stable coins so
if you can join me that was the summary
but then we went into reverse
solicitation and different topics
so how yes here how many minutes uh just
two very short hi guys my name is what's
your name and where I coming from my
name is kakai from Nairobi Kenia and
yeah awesome to be
here uh so yeah our group was talking
about about stable coins but for context
we had to like give at least a bit a
little bit of background from our
perspective on what we understand as
stable coins so fact number one was that
did you know in Kenya alone about $5
billion was transacted in
2024 uh in stab coin transaction and the
average number of consumers in Kenya is
about 3 million people who are actively
using crypto out of a population of 55
million the average uh the number of
stable coin transactions in Nigeria was
uh about $2 billion in 2023 alone now
the biggest use cases for this specific
jurisdiction and it's similar to a lot
of African countries is because there's
a lot of dollar restrictions and dollar
shortages the government really or the
central banks really hold on to the
dollars so there was a very big demand
for a parallel dollar market so all all
everybody is doing Imports exports and
all that uh found stable coins as an
option because with stable coins you
could transact $300 million in trade as
a single entity I mean a bank can't an
African Bank can't give you $300
million and if they did they'll give you
at a very expensive rate stable coin
issues provided very cheap dollar rates
so that was the context for why we are
passionate about stable coins and why a
lot a lot of Kenyans on that table
stable okay awesome so in terms of
stable coin regulations uh African
countries do not have any form of stable
coin regulations but the only country
that has some form of virtual asset
service provider regulations is South
Africa 300 companies have submitted the
applications down there uh we are
working on uh uh pushing for Kenyan
regulations but then again it's vasp or
Casp regulations not stable coin
regulations that means a lot of stable
coins that will be used in Africa for
all those volumes would look towards
Europe for how they're either regulated
in Europe or Japan and Singapore and um
just pick it up from there I mean so
that now diverted our attention to look
at mic what does mic say about stable
coins so there's asset reference tokens
and E money I won't get the details of
that but one uh one two things we
looking at was the mic's requirements on
reserves so first question was uh how
much does mic uh look at how much should
a stable coin issue have at Reserve in
Micah I think it was about
15% but um then uh the mood question was
that only works for guys who are issuing
liquid stable coins like usdc where you
deposit US Dollar on Circle account
Circle mint and they sett in usdc but if
you are doing a bond backed stable coin
like Mountain protocol or like uh or any
other Bond back St coin whereby your
backing is not a liquid Dollar in a bank
but it's actually a treasury bill
how would your classification look like
under mic so we was still brainstorming
on that then number two which is of
Interest was decentralized uh stable
coins so there's an um decentralized
stable coins the question was the M
question again for us to think about was
there's an exemption for and Mica uh on
decentralized projects like um like
decentralized project are sort of
Exempted or they don't want to be dealt
with for now so does that mean that as a
stable as a decentralized stoc coin
issuer I can plead that exemption and
continue circulating my stoc coin across
Europe so that is something to think
about and uh then that now led us to
reverse solicitation and uh offerings
and those conversations around now if
you are offering to Micah to European
Union citizens you need to comply with
Micah or if you're not so so what is
actually the definition of offering is
does the fact that your website is in
French automatically imply that you're
circulating to French citizens if so how
will that look like or should we just uh
shut down yoursite so what is uh how
does shutdown look like so shutdown we
talked about thank you very much we will
need to wrap it
up like with there are three groups each
three minutes so yes thank you again I
tend to take a lot I'm I'm a lawyer
we can continue the discussion
afterwards the next group who's
ready
amazing okay so it looks like I have
nine minutes and 15 seconds on the
screen you have two minutes okay um so
we talked about staking an me um when
you think about staking you almost kind
of put a couple different buckets of
like where the threats to staking right
now one you got things like Igan ler and
reaking two you have things like liquid
staking tokens so the rocket pools and
Leos of the world um and then you have
kind of the idea of meev which touch on
a second and there's the kind of this
fourth bucket of why do Regulators think
that validators are like this Golden
Goose of like if we regulate the
validator this will solve everything um
and that comes down to things like
execution and settlement and also like
who's the actual person effectuating
transactions on the blockchain they want
to think it's the the validator truth is
the validator has like is very simple it
has no role other than to propose
transactions to the network and to
attest to them um this leads us into me
and who knows what proposer Builder
separation is PBS we got a couple that's
essentially this idea that the validator
is this very simple actor they propose
things to the chain they attest to them
on chain and if you allow them to build
the blocks what you're going to create
is a centralizing aspect to where the
person who's the best at building blocks
will actually get all of the stake that
means we will have essentially one
validator for all of ethereum that's not
good so proposer Builder separation is
this um protocol designed to remove the
building aspect from the validator which
we see today on ethereum layer one since
the merge um and it created this role
called The Block Builder um which we see
today there's a couple main block
Builders and that's now another point of
centralization we need to further push
out to the edge um this all comes with
the idea that when you deal with
centralization you want to minimize it
and then push it to the edges on the far
extremes because then you can deal with
them in a much better manner um in the
next 20 seconds I'm going to talk about
me very briefly one me most of it
sandwiching is down 50% over the last
year this is because we have great tools
like orderflow auctions from um Med
blocker and Flash Bots protect then the
thing we need to think about when we
think about me is that most of me is
created when a user makes a mistake on
chain or when a user actually sets
slippage limits too high this happens
because users are not informed about
what they're doing on chain it also
happens because we have terrible uis
from front ends and so as we know how to
minimize um errors from users and create
better front ends over time we're going
to minimize meev even further and
further um I got more thoughts but maybe
your name oh uh Reed lead policy at
flash Bots you can come talk to me thank
you
next
group perfect so what did the defi group
discuss so hello my name is Alison
bti well in our table we talk about uh I
think we focus too much time in what is
decentralized um we U talk that probably
we need just to talk about legal
Frameworks in the world we need to just
have definitions um about what is
decentralized it and what is defi as
well um we discuss about realities uh
Africa reality in legal framework Latin
America reality in or sou America
reality in legal framework um we
conclude and we have to about the
standardization of um regulation that
that could be that the ideal stage of
have regulation in the world but um we
were conss that it could be really hard
because we have difficult different
cultures we we are in different stage of
um crypto and defi uh adopts in
different countries so there were talks
about education that is really important
to have interaction with regulators and
and for them to understand the T issues
and the technical and process of defi
what is defi um we talk about uh the
importance of motivate Regulators as
well to just promote and have
regulations and um understand understood
that that the discussions um important
in regulation is to help protect
consumers as well so um that can be a
motivation for some regulator as well
and some governments so those are some
of those um that's that was the things
we talk about thank
you thank you very much and the last
very important group on
privacy it's very important everyone has
notes so thank you for preparing oh I
have to thank my team for preparing for
me we so uh my name is pranai I'm a
lawyer from India and uh we represent
blockchain and emerging technology a lot
our table was talking about privacy one
of the core things p uh pointed out to
us was at the heart of blockchain is
being able to ID identify everything and
Trace everything so privacy and
blockchain do sort of run against each
other and there has to be a conversation
on how despite the technology being
there to identify every single
individual in the blockchain and
participating the system needs to be
there to effectively allow for privacy
to exist in a blockchain system where
everything is recorded and everything
can be traced down to the last number
and down to the last hash um primarily
by Design it's well whether the platform
or how we integrate privacy layers into
blockchain systems and how say oracles
or uh validators would work towards
maintaining privacy while also being
decentralized is really the challenge
it's also something that they spoke of
on the stable coin part where how do you
uh how do you retain to True
decentralization um to to take the
discussion forward we tried to lean on
what are the current use cases of
blockchain and again the consensus was
that that the real only existing use
case of blockchain right now that's
being effectively used is to move uh
value from one point to another the
transfer of value the transfer of money
and the transfer of funds and if you
talk about that use case the major
challenge right now being faced by
regulators and governments across the
world is privacy and how to uh break
down the Privacy walls and do
enforcement of an anti-money laundering
prevention of uh terrorist financing Etc
while at the same time retaining the
ethos of what is blockchain what is
privacy and what is uh what the
community and the industry really
represents is an autonomy of how to use
software to give yourself the ability to
grow and to do trade effectively which
you weren't able to do
earlier um there are blind spots there
are blind spots that exist even today
that if we do start putting in systems
in place how they may be exploited
tomorrow by regulators and by
governments uh validators or developers
who are oracles or who hold this kind of
data can be forced to give up this data
whether that uh sharing of data is
something the community or the public
agrees with is yet to be seen or tested
so privacy is something that perhaps is
is a larger more granular question that
we're even seeing right now and despite
so many very smart lawyers being on the
table we could not come to any consensus
on any single point of how to or whether
to even preserve privacy there are camps
that say moneya laundering isn't moneya
laundering uh if you look at populations
that have been either systematically or
historically non banked and do not have
access to banking if you go to them and
say that this is money laundering that's
unfair that's discrimination and to a
very large extent it's depriving them of
access to the financial world and that
in itself is what Bitcoin and blockchain
were there to solve so if we add a layer
of of uh identity and take away the
autonomy from Trading digital tokens are
we then excluding a certain set of the
population of this globe from this
technological revolution of being able
to trade through blockchain by adding
the layer of uh identity using a
misnomer perhaps that this is breaking a
law that is money laundering and with
that with 30 seconds left on the clock I
think that was the summary of our
discussion thank
you thank you so much for your
contribution to this workshop and thank
you so much for being an unofficial
Devcon speaker so that is very hard to
achieve so congratulations thanks
everyone for joining us it was really
amazing to have you and uh yeah we hope
to see you in two years
thank you
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
your
oh the
[Music]
d
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]